Donald Trump has just announced that he
has been informed he has been indicted
by the federal government by Biden's doj
relating to the classified documents in
his home this coming on a day when a new
report has come out showing that Joe
Biden received a bribe to fire the
Ukrainian prosecutor from someone in
barisma or I I want to make sure we're
very careful and very clear we've got
what appears to be FBI confirmation that
Joe Biden was bribed the bribery is
related to firing the prosecutor what
many people long suspected or believed
we got a lot of big breaking news to
talk about Donald Trump being indebted a
second time he'll likely be indicted a
third time in Georgia and then we have
the Ronda Sanders campaign using AI
images of Trump trump hugging and
kissing Dr fauci now to be honest that
one's substantially less consequential
than the others but it does pertain to
the election everything so I think we
should bring it up I'm not going to
waste time let's jump right into our
sponsor spot castbrew.com if you want to
support our work cast brew coffee is our
coffee brand go to casper.com purchase
our coffee because it's very very good
really is my favorite and we're
sponsoring ourselves so instead of
relying on other companies to sponsor
the show we started our own company
we're going to build culture we're going
to challenge the machine with your
support we'll keep doing more so go to
castbrew.com but also go to timcast.com
click join us become a member to support
our work because we actually do have a
rather spicy uncensored members only
show coming up at about 10 p.m tonight
you don't want to miss it again not
family friendly but definitely send it
become a member support our work
directly you can follow the show at
timcastirl don't forget to smash the
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends joining
us to talk about this and so much more
is Adam Weiss thanks for having me Tim
uh Adam wayson CEO of amwpr strategic
political Communications company I'm the
guy people call when they're in Rikers
or real crisis situation happens and one
of these old friends of mine who was in
Reich as a destinical just texted me and
said Trump's been indicted again I can't
believe this happened so it's a sad day
in America and uh this shouldn't happen
in our country right on well thanks for
hanging out we also have a lot of el
Yahoo hey what's up everybody I am alad
I'm a reporter here at timcast news you
can find me and other journalists here
at timcast newswork at Twitter uh at
timcast news thanks for having me Tim
right on Seamus Coughlin look who we
have here Eland back again
um I'm I'm Sheamus I'm I'm really
excited for tonight's show I actually
think it's going to be a fun time and I
run a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes we release the video today that's
doing pretty well the audience is really
seeming to enjoy it engage with it so I
would suggest you guys check it out we
were making fun of the new Little
Mermaid reboot as well as other reboots
that do the obnoxious race swapping
thing and then get upset with people for
noticing uh so go over there check it
out I really think you guys are going to
enjoy it we had guest stars uh Adam and
sich on it it's a fun project hello
everyone Ian Crossland I am a wizard and
a shaman uh also we have Serge duprea
hey yeah I'm here uh I'm excited for
today's show good to see you a lot as
always let's do it all right we have
this from truth social Donald Trump has
posted saying the corrupt Biden
Administration has informed my attorneys
that I have been indicted seemingly over
the boxes hoax even though Joe Biden has
1850 boxes at the University of Delaware
additional boxes in Chinatown DC with
even more boxes at the University of
Pennsylvania and documents thrown all
over his garage floor where he Parks his
Corvette and which is quote secured by
only a garage door that is paper thin
and open much of the time he continues I
have been summoned to appear at the
federal courthouse in Miami on Tuesday
at 3 P.M I never thought it would uh I
never thought it possible that such a
thing could happen to a former president
of the United States who received far
more votes than any sitting president in
the history of our country and is
currently leading by far all candidates
both Democrat and Republican in polls of
the 2024 presidential election I am an
innocent man
this is indeed a dark day for the United
States of America we are a country in
serious and Rapid decline but together
we will make America great again
Elon Musk has chimed in responding to
Alx posting this saying there does seem
to be far higher interest in pursuing
Trump compared to other people in
politics very important the justice
justice system rebut what appears to be
differential enforcement or they will
lose public trust Elon I appreciate the
sentiment but you are a couple years too
late it's happening the Federal
indictment by the Biden doj is direct
election interference it is subversion
of the United States election it's just
I don't even know what to say other than
yo look man I don't see how this country
remains on this path I don't see how the
United States stands and continues to
function when you've got the sitting
president filing an indictment against
his chief rival
and the same day and we'll get to in a
minute where evidence is coming out
proving Biden is corrupt and was brought
I was taking bribes well it not just
Biden right the entire political
establishment has been for a very long
time and we've seen selective
prosecutions occur I think in the case
of Dinesh D'Souza it was very obvious
that his prosecution was politically
motivated though he did commit a crime
it's one that typically uh is not
pursued in one which almost never
carries the penalty which he received
which was jail time so this has been
happening for a while here and now
they're just moving on to higher and
higher profile people like the former
president of the United States and one
of the number one polling people who's
currently running in 2024. When Donald
Trump said that he if he was in charge
of the justice system in the United
States Hillary Clinton would be in jail
and an absolutely brilliant moment which
was hilarious and very rhetorically
effective the response from the media
was this sets a very dangerous precedent
now I think it's a little bit different
right because there are things that
Hillary Clinton has done that we can
point to and say
almost anyone else who had done these
things would at the very least be
investigated and very likely be
prosecuted now with Donald Trump what
they're trying to nail him for is having
classified documents even though he as
president had the authority to
declassify them and did so so there's
absolutely nothing here but they want to
lock him up because he is setting an
example for the American people and so
now they need to make one out of him I
shared I sure think that Trump uh I bet
Trump regrets not Prosecuting Hillary
Clinton I was like we're gonna lock her
up and then as soon as he got elected
like we're not gonna do it and now he's
probably really upset that he didn't
because they're coming after him with
with everything they've got well he had
a weak uh uh justice department from the
beginning remember sessions gave in
right away it must have been a month
into the administration yep they went
after Flynn he VP fired Flynn and we sat
through four four years of this Russia
hoax every day CNN MSNBC the whole
mainstream Rush hoax and there was
nothing there but Jeff session appointed
a special prosecutor right off the bat
and we have to live with that you think
do you think America no point a special
prosecutor looking to Joe Biden's five
billion never we have two two uh tears
of Justice in this country I thought it
was interesting that they released this
uh on a Thursday at 7 40 p.m right
before we go live like I'm not saying
we're the center of the universe but do
they want to make a public spectacle is
this more about Trump announced it
that's true that's true I was watching
podcast and I thought quite frankly they
should break it I would love that
um let's see if we get them on the phone
if they want to be amazing if they if
they want to make a public spectacle is
it is the goal here to humiliate Donald
Trump or is the goal to put him in jail
both yeah I think context here is very
important so Donald Trump will be the
first former president who's ever been
indicted on something this is the second
time he's going to be indicted so first
in New York City the Manhattan district
attorney was working with the grand jury
to indict Trump for these so-called hush
money payments to stormy Daniel now we
have the Department of Justice I'm
looking to these classified documents
the second indictment that's ever come
up also there's I think potentially a
third indictment that's going to come
from Georgia
um surrounding efforts to potentially
with what he said with um looking for
votes uh with that whole Scandal there's
also another civil suit against the
Trump organization about lying to
lenders and insurers about his assets
but what's key here is that this is the
first former president to be indicted
and I know there's a myth that nobody's
above the law but guess what the
president and former presidents actually
are above the law there's a lot of
things that people could have thought of
to indict former presidents on we spoke
about it earlier Barack Obama Drew and
American citizens overseed whether or
not that you some people think that's
Justified that's something that could
potentially be indicted on people call
George Bush that say that he started an
illegal war in Iraq but no the first
indictment of a former president that
we're seeing is initially for hush money
payments and now this Declassified
documentary you're gonna start making me
support this I mean if this opens the
door for us to go after former president
and prosecute them man I hope he gets
off and he should but let's do it well
what they say if this is the first
former president no exactly agreed I
agree if they indicted Trump over the
Commando raids in Yemen that resulted in
the death of allegedly the death of an
American Girl abdormalaki's sister that
one is more conjecture than abdulrahman
al-alaki but should be investigated if
they indicted him for that said an
investigation found this to be the case
I'd be like well what do you want me to
say you you ordered these raids and you
kill American citizens you get charged
they're not doing that they're not
because we won't do that because then
everyone's gonna be like Mr Obama right
this way sir into this vehicle you know
what though they're so Shameless that
they would prosecute Trump for something
like that and just not look into Obama
or Biden I mean that's the whole point
people are all criminals and then all
the people on Twitter would be like well
look salute Justified because in this
instance yeah it's also dangerous though
because when a Republican president will
eventually get back into office we will
see attorney generals in different
states say hey let's go indict a former
Democrat let's go investigate until we
find something a good prosecutor it
could indict a rock so right we don't
know what the indictment is right now
it's definitely a process crime which is
kind of a joke and years ago they got
Martha Stewart on a processed crime so
when you bring enough of his staff in
front of the grand jury and somebody
forgets one little thing because they
can't have the exact memory oh the
alliance so it's very easy when you have
the whole weight of the justice
department behind you of millions of
dollars they can get you on anything
this is a real joke they're not going to
get him that he's holding documents
because he's ex-president then you'd
have to go get Biden you'd have to go
get Pence you'd have to go get Obama so
it's just going to be a silly process
crime but they want to stop Trump from
running and they want to stop them from
do you guys want to see when a
republican is eventually president again
that um attorney generals from Red
States go after former Democrat
absolutely and former Republican
Republic
that's not how it would be though it'd
be hyper depends on the Republican but
you're probably right if most
Republicans wouldn't but I think
somebody like Trump would maybe yeah
yeah I think part of what makes this
country green and has made it great is
that we haven't fallen into Petty
squabble like that in not 250 years like
we just don't do that because we have
bigger dishes short short your time span
here buddy okay
860. yeah I mean it's been since the
Civil War you could say right okay but
for the most part Petty squabble that
was that wasn't Petty yeah that was a
big deal we had to end slavery and you
know there was it was a big problem but
this is like just that he said she said
he's carrying a box of documents he's he
he signed this paperwork he ordered that
kill he ordered that kill like yo it's
the biggest military in the world it's
the most dangerous machine on Earth and
someone's got to point the buttons point
the point the guns
um I I just there's so many more bigger
problems on Earth that we should be
focused on than than arresting past
political opponents it's so ridiculous
man
is what's gonna happen well this is
what's really shocking I I shouldn't say
shocking but something worth pointing
out and it's that there are two segments
of the population and they're relatively
large demographics okay these are people
who are either in category a willfully
ignorant or in category B not willfully
ignorant who believe that this is the
first time since Nixon that an American
president has done something worthy of
pursuing with an indictment or charges
there are people are looking at this and
they're saying oh my goodness all of our
presidents have behaved within the law
and haven't committed war crimes haven't
betrayed the American people haven't
betrayed their oath of office and then
Donald Trump came along and there are
good reasons to indict that man and the
best of them is that he had Declassified
documents that he Declassified himself
people are willing to believe this well
the remarkable thing is the logic makes
no sense if Trump can't declassify
anything at any time then he's literally
not the authority of this country to
have conversations pertaining to war how
can you be the commander-in-chief of the
Armed Forces and then this is the
example I gave last time it's like you
meet with Vladimir Putin and he's like
you know I want you to move these
missiles out of this territory what
missiles yeah okay we know the U.S has
missiles here you move them otherwise
it's War I'm sorry I can't confirm our
deny I don't have the authority Biden
probably does say what missiles though
to be fair it's like what are you
talking about man I don't know what you
mean
it's on the phone he's like are there
missiles in Ukraine there are oh man you
think the implications and then he gets
off the line he's like I don't know if
there's missiles there I think that the
implication is that Donald Trump didn't
declassify the documents before there's
no process for it okay the president has
plenary declassification powers he can
literally just be like these are no
longer classified so I I had him on me
therefore they're not classified anymore
he did say they were Declassified but
they're like arguing there's some kind
of formal process by which the president
does not needs to get approval from
someone else but they're not going after
him on this apparently
the report is that they're charging him
with losing possession of classified
documents or something like that or of
of sensitive National Security documents
so they're actually trying to avoid the
question of whether or not he classified
or Declassified by saying it's a totally
different law now losing acts losing
control of secured documents is
something Hillary Clinton did when she
would forward all that stuff to Jake
Sullivan like out of her thirty thousand
emails or whatever she had there's there
I've you know I should have one that I
could pull up right now that was
legitimate National Security risk but
she was as far as I understand not
supposed to be forwarding you know
Secretary of State documents to this guy
Jake Sullivan well Ian I think there's a
good argument to be made that every
single one of the 30 000 emails that
Hillary Clinton deleted was a potential
National Security risk if she were to be
elected for one very simple reason she
didn't want people to see those emails
and there was a receiver which means
there were people who would have the
leverage over the sitting president of
the United States of being able to
release these emails that she deleted
when she was subpoenaed so
that in and of itself means that someone
else could end up pulling the strings or
someone else could end up uh being in a
position where the president owes them
this favor because they have blackmail
you mean because someone else received
documents from Hillary anyone could have
them well no my point is so Hillary
Clinton has these 30 000 emails and then
she deletes all of them because she
clearly doesn't want an investigation to
be looking into those emails she doesn't
want the American people to see them
well here's the thing she can only
delete those emails on her end she can't
go into the inbox of every person who
received one of those emails and then
deleted which means there are people who
had the emails that she didn't want the
public to see which means those people
have dirt on her have you know quote
unquote information that could lead to
the arrest of Hillary Clinton and for as
much as we joke about what happens to
those people and for as much as I've
said I think the real black pill is that
no amount of information will lead to
the rest of Hillary Clinton the fact is
it is a massive liability for the
president of the United States to have
information out there that people can
blackmail them on a Blackberry CNN's
reporting it is seven counts in the end
indictment according to sources they
came into for the first one like 31
counts I think of that first indictment
and it was like this is the same count
for it was like one problem and they
because the right problem was you know
in in 30 different emails they were like
it's 30 different counts that's what
they do man I don't even wanna it was
more than 50 000 pages of private emails
uh for Hillary by the way I don't even
want to prosecute Hillary I just want
people to know about it funny enough no
is it the only thing you need to
prosecute it Louie we do I was kind of
glad he didn't go through with it and I
was devastated when he said that on
stage because it really did set a
precedent I thought
I said uh Trump's not the only president
with classified document problems
because Joe Biden is also under
investigation right now for something
similar handling the mishandling of
classified documents so if you speed up
that investigation too well and I would
take it a step further because a VP
can't declassify neither can a senator
right he's the president now but there's
reason to believe that he stored these
uh while he was VP or while he was a
Senator but I'm sorry continue going
back to what what Hillary it was only
James Comey the that brilliant FBI
director we had at the time sat in front
of had a major press government said she
did 10 things wrong but I'm not going to
pursue her could you imagine Merrick
Garland or Jack Smith saying well Trump
did 10 things wrong but it's not we're
not going to go after him never so never
again well ladies and gentlemen we do
have more news because it's a heck of a
day in this country I just want to
mention one thing no yeah it was um the
documents were specifically discovered
in a place that he was using before the
start of the 2020 campaign right so
these documents Biden had had to have
been collected while he was either VP or
in the senate in either case he could
not declassify or not in office at all I
mean if he got him in 2017 he wasn't
even serving it in any capacity at that
point so Joe Biden is actually at the
same time as Trump is being indicted Joe
Biden is being implicated in a bribery
scheme which is it's expanding we've
known about it Fox news reports Joe
Biden allegedly paid five million
dollars by barisma executive as part of
a bribery scheme according to FBI
document Biden's son Hunter was a board
member of bursma and also allegedly in
on the scheme it's actually fairly
simple they wanted the prosecutor fired
the post-millennial reports MTG reveals
FBI informant reported Biden was bribed
to have the Ukrainian prosecutor fired
who was investigating barisma on
Thursday rep MTG held an emergency event
after reading the FBI's fd-1023 form
that alleges a bribery scheme involving
Joe Biden during his days as vice
president revealing that payments were
made to the Biden family by barisma the
Ukrainian oil company which Hunter Biden
sent on the board of
back in 2015-16 barismo was looking to
buy a U.S based oil and gas company and
this came from being advised by Hunter
Biden advised by Hunter Biden and his
Partners Biden said Victor shoken was
corrupt this is around the same time of
his meeting which was when Joe Biden's
vice president said that prosecutor
shoken was corrupt so we basically know
what happened
Joe Biden goes to Ukraine threatens the
president he says if you don't fire the
prosecutor you're not getting the loan
guarantees which is illegal he doesn't
have the authority to do that those are
congressionally approved loan guarantees
they told him that and he says call the
president see what he says he says well
SOB guy gets fired and then we got in
someone good which is a complete
fabrication
Victor shulkin the prosecutor was
investigating barisma I think there was
at least a dozen or more active
investigations and now we have from this
FBI document what appears to be
confirmation
it's all true the quid pro quo in this
situation I remember a president getting
um impeached for something like that
yeah yeah quid pro quo I remember
hearing that uh right remember that
phrase so much constantly this is the
pro to the quid pro
Donald Trump for what Joe Biden did and
now they are trying to indict Donald
Trump for something Joe Biden also did
also did and all Trump did was say can
you look into this that's all you know
also but even this right I get the point
you're making but it's it's a false
equivalency because
with the store with the store documents
Biden had no power to declassify and
Trump did so people say these are the
same thing it's like well no it's not
because what Biden did was worse
and same here right I don't know how to
verify if they're Declassified or not
because what if what if Obama's like oh
yeah I Declassified all that stuff by
he's got in his garage yes he's the full
he was there yeah he wasn't the
President Obama but but if Obama if we
found Obama had documents well he was
the President right but if there's if
the VP has documents that Obama declass
oh I get what you're saying I'm sorry I
misunderstood uh well we would need
Obama to come forward and say oh yes
I'll give those to him and said go keep
them keep them in your garage that's a
good idea and leave some at your weird
like little office I'm trying to talk do
that good job like maybe maybe but I we
have no reason to believe it man I want
to know more about this FBI release if
if you took it we're all into politics
we watched this every day but if you
took an average group of people that
didn't watch politics and you lined them
up and you said the crime Trump had
documents Biden 5 million so and so
I guarantee 90 of them said what Biden
did is by far the worst and Tim if you
Google right now I bet nobody has this
covered in the media except yeah Mike
cernovich pointed out they timed the
indictment with the uh day of release
yeah the the barisma information however
if if that's true Trump's the one who
posted about it to be fair though CNN
did report it as well so maybe Trump
came out and said this because it was
getting picked up I think they were
planning on releasing it next week is
what I saw the indictment announcement
but maybe because this was dropping
today they were like let's just get it
out early yeah CNN's reporting on the
issue came uh 40 minutes after Trump's
uh truth post so does it cycle just
truth post uh it does yeah yeah someone
came out and wrote the story get ahead
of it DT right it may be that Trump is
the one who uh uh basically look the
headline for this episode of Tim cast
IRL before the Donald Trump and Diamond
came down was Joe Biden barisma scandal
report confirms bribery blah blah blah
hour reporting on and now the lead story
is Trump that is exactly what the media
narrative would like it to be anyway
they want us to be talking about Donald
Trump right now and not Biden this is I
got to know more about this FBI document
I mean I don't know what to trust who to
trust I know there's a lot of evidence
that Biden went over there and did some
dirty work to get that prosecutor fired
I mean he admitted it in public and
asked about it yeah
um so last time Trump was indicted he
raised 34 million dollars and what got a
little boost in the poll as a result of
this what do you guys think the
Electoral consequences of this will be
moving this is a Federal indictment this
is big do you think it'll give him a
bump and more like a rally around our
guy effect as a result of this I have to
wonder if they really just want Trump to
be the nominee they definitely wanted
yeah but do you think that's what the
move here was to make it seem like we're
going after Trump trump and then make
you know all the Republicans defend him
because now what is the Santa's gonna
say about this well I don't know what
the move was or whether it was
intentional but what I will say is even
though earlier I alluded to the fact the
fact that there are some Americans out
there in a disturbingly large number of
Americans who think that you know this
is the first time in decades a president
has done anything illegal or worth uh
Civil Authorities looking into the
reality is most people do know that's
not true and so when one president is
indicted by A system that they know is
corrupt and that they know allows for
Elites to commit crimes and is allowed
for other presidents to commit crimes
they go interesting why him right he
must be doing something that's different
from all the things these political
leaders have been doing to screw us for
a very long time I think people on both
sides of the aisle and moderates can see
that if you're a democratic strategist
you want Trump in the general and then I
don't I'm I mean indictments are
political all of this is obviously
political but then indicting him to try
to make it more uh
more popular in the primary is would be
a decent Democratic strategy so that's
true oh you make them more popular in
the primary than in the general you make
it so he can't that he has to you want
him in the general because theoretically
DeSantis does better against Biden but
also I'm thinking if you're indicted it
doesn't play as well to a general
audience as it would to a primary
audience yeah well oh sorry the vibe I
get is that he they want to make it so
that Donald Trump cannot run for
president again which is going to
inflame so many millions and tens of
millions of people why on Hell's Green
Earth would they do that I mean maybe
they really believe that Donald Trump
would win this one person who is that
authority to Pardon him Joe Biden right
now what if he does you know just be a
nice guy of course man Superman yeah I
want to see some Biden Superman memes if
that happens but that's you know that'd
be an awesome coming together moment if
Trump was and died for some and then you
know um Biden just you know told him hey
it's okay because if you're indicted by
the feds this is hard this is really
hard to get out of yeah because then I
can be like make America great again to
Trump and Trump's like I will let's put
this partisanship behind us we don't
need to indict Trump let's just drop it
now let's move forward but the thing is
it's almost not partisanship because
there are a lot of Republicans they
would never do this too we we have but
look what's happening right now we have
news Joe Biden was allegedly paid five
million dollars as part of the barisma
bribery scheme and we just keep going
back to Trump yeah
I don't know I don't know if that was
the right play by Trump to be posting
about this because we would be just
going heavy into Hunter Biden the crack
the diary all of this stuff instead it's
like yes Joe Biden did this thing and
anyway here's Trump he funded so much
after the first indictment I'm sure he's
going to raise a ton of money after the
second indictment too but so so this is
an interesting point you're making
because I've said in the past I think
it's very possible that the left-wing
establishment is trying to engage in
another attempt at the Pied Piper
strategy they want him to try to run for
president or not just try but for him to
get the nomination because they think
he'll lose a general election
but I've heard other people who believe
that Trump would lose the general
election kind of make the opposite
argument to the one you're making so I
was having a conversation with Will
Chamberlain a couple of months ago on my
podcast and this was right when the
documents being found at Joe Biden's uh
house was a news story and asked him why
do you think that they would be leaking
this now and his response was basically
I think the reason they're leaking this
now is because they don't want to
prosecute Trump because that might
prevent him from running and they want
him to run so I think Prosecuting him or
not Prosecuting him could be taken as
the Democrats wanting him to be able to
run in 2024 so it's tough to say he can
run either way but I think what they
want to make sure is he is hindered from
campaigning but they gotta know I mean
maybe they really don't know how good no
this is for his publicity what what if
what if Joe Biden gets indicted because
of this story you know the other story
that we were talking about the five
million that he received allegedly
everyone who runs just gets indicted is
another VP is getting divided to a
smaller jail no one knows what to do to
win so it's just different law
enforcement agencies indicting each
other that's your campaign now local
sheriff is just like oh Joe Biden once
was speeding in my neighborhood it's
like well I guess he's got to come to
court and can't campaign anymore where's
the uh we haven't really read into this
story much do you know what this alleged
payment was for exactly to get the
prosecutor fired yeah it was just
straight I guess we did it was so
straightforward like hey here get this
guy fired barisma was being investigated
by the prosecutor there were a dozen or
more investigations and then Joe Biden
swoops in and gets the guy fired and
then the investigation stuff they send
it to like Family Trust or something I
don't even Family Trust I mean we saw
those emails we know about 10 for the
big guy we know that this is what
they've been doing let me just add these
layers and bring these stories together
for you Joe Joe Biden is is is the
president right now it is his Department
of Justice going after Donald Trump
Donald Trump said can you please look
into this so they impeach him then Joe
Biden becomes president and now is going
after Trump presumably because he's the
only one who knows not literally but
he's going after the guy that tried to
take him down and if Donald Trump gets
elected you know Joe Biden's in serious
trouble and his family is too so Biden's
probably alike screw it burn it all down
hmm
but I mean this is what's what really
tricks me out man is that these people
would put selfish needs and wants and
desires ahead of the good of of humanity
that's why they're in politics so we we
uh Donald Trump posted a video a video
response we're going to play this video
for you right now we have this from
truth social he says I'm an innocent man
the bite Administration is totally
corrupt this election this is election
interference and and a continuation of
the greatest Witch Hunt of all time make
America great again let's uh let's play
the video
get some lighting on your face Don and
yet thank you
very sadly We're a nation of decline
and yet they go after a popular
president a president that got more
votes than any sitting president in the
history of our country by far
and did much better the second time in
the election than
the first and they go after him on a
Box's hoax just like the Russia Russia
Russia hoax and all of the others this
has been going on for seven years they
can't stop because it's election
interference at the highest level
there's never been anything like what's
happened I'm an innocent man I'm an
innocent person they had the Mueller
hoax the Mueller report and that came
out no collusion after two and a half
years that was set up by Hillary Clinton
and Democrats but this is what they do
this is what they do so well if they
would devote their energies to honesty
and integrity would be a lot better for
our country they could do a lot better
they could do a lot of great things but
when you look at what's happened to our
country in the last three years we were
energy independent we had a strong
military that wasn't woke we were doing
so well we were respected all over the
world got the biggest tax cuts in
history biggest regulation Cuts in
history and what do you do you have a
president where an election was taken
got more votes than any sitting
president in history by far never
anything even close
and they come after me because now we're
leading in the polls Again by a lot
against Biden and against the
Republicans by a lot but we're leading
against Biden by a lot a tremendous
amount
and we went up to a level that they
figured the way they're going to stop us
is by using what's called Warfare
and that's what it is this is Warfare
for the law and we can't let it happen
we can't let it happen our country is
going to hell and they come after Donald
Trump weaponizing the justice department
weaponizing the FBI we can't let this
continue to go on because it's ripping
our country to shreds we have such big
problems and this shouldn't be one of
them it's a hoax the whole thing is a
hoax just like Russia Russia Russia just
like the fake dossier was a hoax you saw
the Durham report you saw the Mueller
report it was all a big hoax you had two
impeachments and they lost and we won
and we had tremendous support
but that was a hoax and a scam and now
they're doing it again it's just a
continuation seven years even after I'm
out but it's called election
interference they're trying to destroy a
reputation so they can win an election
that's just as bad as doing any of the
other things that have been done over
the last number of years and especially
during the 2020 election
so I just want to tell you I'm an
innocent man I did nothing wrong and we
will fight this out just like we've been
fighting for seven years it would be
wonderful if we could devote our
full-time to making America great again
and that's exactly what we did but now
again our country is in Decline we're a
failing nation and this is what they do
I'm an innocent man we will prove that
again seven years of proving it and here
we go again very unfair but that's the
way it is I just want to thank everybody
we are doing something very special for
our country we're putting America first
I always put America first
and that's why we were in a position
unfortunately that position is no longer
valid because they've done such a poor
job
but we're in a position where we're
going to make America great again I'm
innocent and we will prove that very
very soundly and hopefully very quickly
thank you very much I think you said I'm
innocent like yeah that would make if
someone cut that up and made an
auto-tune of a song called I'm an
innocent man that would be so badass
that actually would be and he is
innocent until proven guilty he's
innocent yeah I think he's just genuine
generally innocent because I don't
believe anything they're living against
him so yeah Mr Weiss you're a crisis guy
right so I'm gonna say a lot what's
going on here a lot of times I have this
scenario with uh clients and the lawyer
the lawyers always say don't speak don't
speak and I say don't listen to lawyers
they're just gonna hold you back it's
very important that President Trump
spoke right now 50 60 million people
want to hear from he showed strength he
showed confidence
he showed that he's still in High
Spirits because most probably most of
his attorneys saying don't say anything
don't go out there keep it quiet you
might slip you might say something to
Trump you never know but it's very
important I think tonight that he spoke
out and I would have given the advice
speak out
what if like he posted if anyone who's
crying
like behind a bed sheet or something
like Chris Crocker
he's just a huge what kind of human goes
through this it's unbelievable seven
years of torture and he's still trying
to still trying to run but Trump's the
kind of guy I imagine when the camera
goes off he starts like punching the
wall he doesn't think so yeah I don't
think he's the kind of person who's like
I can't believe there's doing this to me
like where would they step he's the kind
of guy was like oh I will destroy them
build me something great so I can
destroy it'll be another one I bet he's
like raising his voice I bet he's going
to his lawyers back why isn't anything
getting done how is this still happening
I want lawyers yeah he looked like he
was freaking out I was there the night
he got indicted from the uh the city
district attorney and he was he flew
right in and did a big speech at
Mar-A-Lago we went upstairs afterwards
and he's DJing the whole night two in
the morning what like on the record
he takes his iPad he takes the iPad when
he's there and he's he becomes the DJ
that's always the tune are you serious
he's like just picking music that night
yeah he's just he goes he's pretty okay
he goes from Sinatra to Elton John I'd
rather imagine it was like the one
headphones he ruined that by giving more
details
he just got indicted
in the morning and having a great time I
said unbelievable I think he's a TJ he's
like getting in diet reviews the coolest
president we've ever had that's not even
a question
like he's probably got a lot of
streakers trouble with the law yeah we
did a cartoon about that a little while
ago and now it's happening again it's
like I don't know why I bothered to keep
making these every week when the news is
just reruns now yeah one of my favorite
lines from him that he says constantly
and he said it a couple times in this
speech is that he received the most
votes of any sitting president
specifically because Biden wasn't a
sitting president obviously at the time
but he keeps saying that the most votes
of any sitting president he's not
sitting right now quite frankly he's
laying he's laying down you know he's
not awake it's just like a funny cop-out
when he's not the president right now
and he just keeps saying it's true
though it is true from a sitting
president yeah but I've still got more
votes but his point is no other uh uh
what is it no other sitting president
received more votes and lost sure we're
a growing population with more voter
participation every four years so it's
like uh
well I think I think I think we've never
had more money in our economy than we do
right now
covid played a major role in why this
didn't look the same way as it did
because they basically just locked
everybody in boxes and then tortured him
for it and then mail-in ballots that
played a huge role which DeSantis said
he wants to start doing aggressively and
we'll see if Trump follow
I just think like
the the fabric of this nation has been
ripped to shreds oh yeah and now it's
just
you know before it was things were
heating up now at the highest level like
the fact that the Biden doj is just like
well I can't beat him so let's lock him
in jail but like okay ripping the fabric
apart if the fabric is being used to
suffocate your friend and you rip the
fabric to shreds and save your friend's
life that maybe that fabric needed to be
ripped apart anyway so like are we
better off or worse off since Trump
became president not Hillary but that
that doesn't quite make sense right the
the fabric of this country is what stops
the people from from fighting each other
in the streets the fabric of this
country is the basic rule set of look
we're not going to indict our political
rival we're going to let people vote
about these things we're not going to
make up BS charges right now in the
public sphere we know for a fact Joe
Biden is corrupt Politico wrote about
this years ago Biden Inc we know that
his family's fortunes have tracked his
career in in federal government we now
have another story basically confirming
he was getting bribes to fire the
prosecutor Joe Biden publicly admitted
he went to the president of Ukraine and
said fire the prosecutor or I will
illegally withhold loan guarantees he
just come out and said it and they don't
do anything about it if the people of
this country know for a fact that the
government has been weaponized against
one half of the population like we are
dangerously close to whatever you want
to call it yeah oh boy the metaphor you
were looking for Ian was like um a
fracture doesn't heal fully but you need
to break the arm completely for it to
heal fully not that I agree with what if
that's what breaks if your bone is
fractured then it doesn't heal
completely but if it breaks completely
then it does properly heal that's a bad
metaphor for what I think should happen
in the nation but I think that's a
cleaner metaphor for what you're looking
for a clean break you know Biden is so
fascinating to me he's this uh he's like
for as much as people say this about
Trump Biden is this character study in
the hubris of man because he's so late
in his life and he's putting such little
emphasis on his soul in so much emphasis
on money and being corrupted Family
First
he's well firstly Kennedy if we're
including fake Catholics Kennedy was a
fake Catholic President before Joe Biden
uh no I think Kennedy was actually
practicing but we know behind the scenes
yeah we know there were some some
going on there that would throw him
outside of like you know you know he was
not practicing my point is yeah yeah no
I know you can't trust those guys that's
my whole argument
Joe Biden I mean
politics Irish flag behind you tonight I
know what are you talking about when was
there everyone
you know the Catholics don't need to get
into politics because the Vatican has so
much power I don't know about that dude
I don't step down into the politics
realm they already
know but if you think religious
institutions may have more influence and
power over Earth than sitting
governments I mean but well that's the
thing you know I'm Catholic I love my
church but you know there are obviously
people in the Catholic church I've been
very critical of and people in the
hierarchy and I think it was Chesterton
who said this but one of the reasons I
believe it's the True Churches because I
don't know how an organization can spend
so much time being corrupt and still
exist it's been like 2 000 years with
these horrible reasons we're still here
who's gonna have faith in the justice
system anymore after this oh no but
after this after January it's such a
joke they got to do something good I
mean for me to regain faith in them
they'd have to do something we have
videos of Hunter Biden that you can't
show even an 18 year old agreed but you
know what you know what I'll I'll say is
that at this point we've become so
tribal that credibility is irrelevant
right people are gonna side with their
team even if they know their lying let's
let's like dirty politics we have this
story from timcast.com DeSantis campaign
uses AI generated deep fake images of
trump embracing fauci into it yes yes
hugging and kissing and I also want to
point out look at Trump's see his hand
right here look at Trump's seven foot
long arm
he's embracing fauci and his arm goes
all the way around Factory like just
think about how long his left arm is and
how he's holding fouchy and then how his
other arm wraps all the way around yeah
it's clearly a deep fake and so this is
this is the DeSantis war room they ran
an ad says Donald Trump became a
household name by firing countless
people on television but when it came to
fauci in the video they run this image
it says real life Trump and the top left
the bottom Mill and bottom right are AI
generated images of trump hugging and
kissing Dr fauci wow now look
people like this people thought this was
real this this video I believe it's
actually from it's from uh
what is it from June 5th I think the
original post is actually a few a few
days before but let's just say June 5th
because that's the date listed on
Twitter
nobody knows anything until today I saw
people posting saying hey wait a minute
the DeSantis campaign generated fake
images to smear Donald Trump as favoring
Dr fauci you don't need to smear Trump
he wouldn't fire the guy he says he
couldn't schedule F that I understand
but he very much let Dr fauci do his
thing during covid the fact that they
went this far they opened the gates
yo this is look we're talking about
indictments we're talking about the doj
welcome to Modern politics they're going
to start generating fake AI images of
you doing something to smear you and
this is a serious ad meant to make
people believe Donald Trump actually was
good friends with fauci oh my gosh they
should have a disclaimer that that's
fake because a cartoon you would know
they're defending it they're doubling
down all the decision supporters are
doubling down hardcore saying we are
allowed to do this because Donald Trump
once posted a picture of Rhonda said is
writing a rhinoceros which everyone
thought was real of course at the time
and you know people didn't want to
Santos because of the animal cruelty uh
here's a picture of Ron on a rhinoceros
and and the response I got was hey Tim
what diss because I said the the
intentional Act of making a fake image
putting it in a collage to trick people
into thinking that Trump was was liked
Dr fauci
is one million times different from
Trump insulting Ron DeSantis also yeah
no in in there's context to those
photographs too which you mentioned it's
in a collage of other photographs but
they're talking about Trump being too
soft on fauci and it's a real life Trump
on it it will and Trump was not making
any specific Claim about firstly it's
poorly photoshopped it's obviously a
joke but secondly Trump was not making
like a claim about DeSantis riding
rhinos
so so everybody responded to me saying
why aren't you disavowing Donald Trump
for his use of deep fakes and I said
what what use and they post that and I'm
like that's a Photoshop of Ron on a
rhinoceros are you joking and you know
it's fake he has a suit on well right
my favorite Putin riding a bear and they
said yeah they said Donald Trump made a
fake posted a fake AI Twitter space and
I said you mean with the devil and
Hitler so here's what I tweeted I said
you know what they're all mad I say I
hereby disavow Trump for posting a video
of the devil and Hitler in a chat room
making fun of DeSantis Manny DeSantis
supporters thought it was real and it
was wrong for Trump to post it then when
this guy tweets at me what about this
picture and it's Trump writing or it's
Rhonda said is writing a rhinoceros I
said I once again I hereby once again
disavowed Donald J Trump he posted a
picture of Rhonda said as writing a
rhinoceros and many of the Santa
supporters thought it was real it was
wrong of trump to mislead these people
in this way and Trump must apologize for
confusing to Santa supporters with this
image and the dude deleted it
the the the argument that you can make
fake news fake images to trick people is
in no way the same as Trump being a dick
and then people are like how come what
about Alex bruceowitz he posts memes yes
there there was an image of George
Charles in the background somewhere and
then he posted something this was
another thing they're criticizing him
for where he said apparently this wasn't
George Soros but I have to wonder and
it's like okay and then other people
random people online who are not Donald
Trump and associated with his campaign
posted photoshopped images of like
Christina Pasha and other people in the
Santa's Camp there is a big difference
between Ron desantis's official campaign
his staff producing fake images to trick
people into thinking Trump did a thing
he did not do and Trump posting a
picture of Rana rhinoceros but I'm sorry
I guess if they really believe that
happened they were like Well Ron never
wrote a rhinoceros Trump's lying but
here's the thing I'm a highly trained
skeptic so when I saw that picture of
Ron and a rhinoceros I didn't think it
was real but I thought man this deep
fake technology is getting really
convincing that's right this is clearly
Ron DeSantis on a rhino I'm sorry like
dude you can by all means criticize any
Trump supporter for posting fake
information 100 but the idea that
because some people associated with
Trump posted questionable things they
found on the internet justifies the
intentional Act of posting deep fakes to
lie about Donald Trump this is It's
laughably absurd sorry have a nice day I
I was saying before that I was like you
know I really like to see at this he
does great in Florida he's given us
everything he's wanted his Charisma is
not there I'm leaning towards Trump
simply because Trump's likely to fire
all these people now there is absolutely
no way I will support Rhonda Santos
unless he comes out explicitly
disavowing the use of deep fakes to
manipulate people
I think that probably these strategists
he has all this money sense of how do we
go let's keep on this fouchy Crusade
that he was so close to vouch you
wouldn't fire him and maybe the pictures
didn't have that hug so let's just shove
in the hug right let's just add these
two extra pictures it will really push
the envelope and show how close they
were and people won't pick up on it
that's fake but you know not just to hug
a kiss like you know they could have
just settled for a hug they got one
where he's smooching them right on the
nose there they wrote real life Trump
they show a bunch of real clips of trump
saying why he wouldn't fire fauci
legitimate criticism and then it says
real life Trump and it shows him hugging
and kissing look at this to the left the
White House the the room doesn't even
make sense but the White House emblem it
says
because AI can't make language they
could have at least voted so what was
their argument that real life was only
written on the pictures that were
actually literally real so they weren't
trying to they were no no no that's what
they're saying the one no there's
nothing this was on it I don't believe
it yes it is oh those were in the ad yes
I'll play the ad for you I'll pull it up
these are in the ad like let's play this
here you go you're fired you're all
fired all four are fired you're fired
today I walk in I hear I'm gonna fire
him I'm not firing I think he's a
wonderful guy should you have fired
fouchy so a lot of people ask me that
question and I did it right because if
you do fire them you're going to have a
Firestone on the left again why why did
you feel unable to fire effect
allowed to every time he goes on
television there's always a bomb but
there's a bigger bomb of your firearm
frankly
you can't win that one if I would have
done it I would have taken heat all
right I'm gonna say when it said real
life Trump on a picture of him hugging
fouchy that isn't real Trump has grounds
to sue yes yeah well absolutely look at
this it's in the video and there's a uh
we've got bird watcher whatever it's
called Community notes at at 25 seconds
in this video a collage of photos of
President Trump hugging Anthony fauci
appear these pictures are not real they
are at AI generated images and it says
real life Trump I think that while
quoting Trump fake fake fake to Santa's
campaign should get ahead of this and be
like these were deep fakes before they
get sued into Oblivion oh no no dude
there's no debate anymore you're right
you're right there's no debate any any
now debate Rhonda Sanders tries to have
with Trump trump wins instantly he's
gonna set the Ron is going to be like
Donald Trump wouldn't fire Dr fauci and
Trump's gonna be like fake news he made
fake photos and ran those I can here it
is and said they were
and I've been very clear about where I
stand on Trump versus DeSantis but I
will say that undermines one of the good
points that Santa's actually does have
about Trump that that undermines one of
the good arguments against Trump even
though I support him to say yeah he
didn't fire fauci that was a serious
flaw he should have is something that is
credible and it's powerful and to
completely undermine that by having a
generated picture of him kissing fouchy
on the nose while he hugs him
yeah hey wife what would your crisis
response team be to something like this
double down or what to the Santos how
does your response be probably should
disavow or if he fired somebody that
created this then it would he's got to
find the top blame somebody else
subordinate say this was their idea I
didn't put them in fake photos in an ad
it's not just putting up a meme on
Twitter it's different right you had to
go through a whole process let's make
the ad let's make it scoop what do you
put here put the photo and somebody said
let's put two fake
three
and the scientist has to know about it
they had to bring him the ad at the end
yeah what I noticed didn't happen it's
possible that Santas didn't go I'm
Rhonda santis and I approve this message
they used to have to do that or would do
that in commercials it's possible even
if rack but impact no this is warm it
was it was according to multiple reports
Christina Pasha who employed directly by
DeSantis run made this account I don't
know who made the video but it's
possible to Santa saw the video and it's
a 40 second video and he looks at he's
like it's great run it not realizing
they put deep fakes in it yeah but I
think if they try and pull a we didn't
know and so we're gonna hire John
herbowitz he was the one who did it I
will not be satisfied I don't know who
that is you can't come to me and say
underling is at fault nah sorry look man
we knew this was coming we've warned
about it it's one thing and it's bad
enough that they cut Trump out of
context and lie about him it is also bad
enough that there are people who support
Trump that make fake things and then
they get shared by people in the trump
in the Trump camp like in in like the
Trump's Circle and things like that but
to intentionally run an ad with fake
images to smear your political opponent
is crossing the line directly and it
opens the door to a very dark future
that's why it's like hey we knew someone
was going to do it Rhonda Santa said he
was going to lead out but man it says re
that this is real it says real life
Trump with a picture of him that is not
real life Trump so good God what did you
guys do this really opens up the
floodgates for RFK to do it to ads
against Biden right I just we were
talking about this before the show and I
was just saying I can't imagine Trump's
going to run ads Trump is going to make
an ad and it's going to be it's going to
be like some woman it's gonna packs are
gonna do this so if you're gonna hear a
woman go Ron desantis's campaign is
making fake images of trump to smear him
don't trust dishonest Ron they're going
to be running that like crazy it'll be
like an image of a serpent with Ron's
head on it and stuff like that all these
wild deep things and it's gonna say real
life Ron I'm a fisherman
but but anything now that Rhonda Santa
says Trump can easily be like are you
gonna believe him the guy who makes fake
images to win arguments I like I don't
want to insult Ron but I get the vibe
that like he's just a guy that was in
the right place at the right time that
he's not really special he's not really
super smart he doesn't have the best
people around him and now they want him
in the public because they don't like
Donald Trump so anyone will do this
guy's establishment let's just get him
up there he'll be fine I disagree I
think that's a little harsh so I um
again I I prefer Trump as of now but
also
um DeSantis is somebody who did stand up
to the covid regime and the lockdown
regime and he pushed back against it and
he did stand up to the meeting I do
think he's very intelligent I wouldn't
go as far as to say he's just like a a
mediocre politician like the rest of
them I think he's a step above
it I will vote was was groundbreaking
yeah almost You could argue that it
saved the Republic in a way or was a it
was a it was an indication of how to
save a republican I I will not I won't I
won't support
this campaign choosing to focus on um
fauci specifically is a genius move it
is such a potent attack especially
because there are so many Trump
supporters who do have so many questions
about operation warp speed and fauci but
they just overplayed their their hand
for no good reason this was like a very
stupid misplay you didn't have to do it
Trump was already praising operation
warp speed still he didn't fire fauci
for whatever reason and that's a whole
different conversation and they could
have kept hitting him on this but such
an unforced error is so stupid and the
response from desantis's Hardcore fans
is it's almost as if they're actually
leftists or Trump supporters trying to
sabotage Ron DeSantis you you can't come
out and be like but but Trope posted run
on a rhinoceros if if that's your
argument you're just trying to make the
Santa supporters look really really dumb
like there's no argument yeah literally
should come out and be like these got
mixed in we didn't like they could say
we didn't make these we saw them we put
it in the ad it's our mistake we didn't
check we disavow we apologize it'll
never happen again if it's true I don't
want them live I think people you know
I'm saying that's their best out in my
opinion but or it could be like the guy
that created this it was an oversight on
my part I didn't realize the amount of
damage it could do to the political
process and he's fired and I'm not gonna
ever do this again we should say if a
Deepak is if you don't know the person
they're firing actually did it true
that's what I wanted they're gonna say
some random name they're gonna say you
know Ian Coughlin is the guy who did it
so he's fired and then Ian coughlin's
gonna be like I just work in the mail
room
doesn't matter they they stick a name to
it and they say yeah we're good well I
wanted to I want to be honest about it I
wanted to honestly take the person a
task that created this and thought it
was a good idea we are we are we are a
next year deep fake technology will be
100 fold better than this I'm concerned
what's going to happen is only after the
ashes do people realize we need to
legislate this went unnoticed for three
days I believe I believe it was posted
June 5th yep at 3 P.M so this went
unnoticed for three days and it could
have easily continued to have gone
unnoticed and I think that just speaks
to the future of what we are going to
see with much more compelling AI we
didn't catch this uh like Tim said like
oh the wording was off if somebody's
kept like took a good eye to this they
would have been able to spot it but
three days there's gonna be a ton of
stuff that a lot of people miss a lot of
articles are probably written about it
smaller ones being like DeSantis hits
Trump on on fauci and then they did not
realize yep I mean it really is going to
get to a point where we look back and we
say anything that was published before
2023 as far as photography figos can be
inspected to see if it's photoshopped or
not so we can trust that
um we're not going to be able to point
but I think even a point before 2023
because maybe there are people who have
this technology before it became widely
available and we're using it and we'll
find out about that at some point who
knows but I I think that's gonna we are
going to get to a point we'll kind of
only be able to verify things
so wrong when I went on Rogan and he
asked me about deep fake technology and
I said no I'm not super concerned
because people left trust and he asked
me if I thought it was going to get bad
and I said I didn't think so and now
that it's all happening it's just like
it is going to be worse than anyone
realizes what what's going to happen is
we're going to get to a point where
where what they're going to say is any
image generated after 2023 is not real
and you're going to be like well clearly
some of them are real like yes but they
can never be they're no longer
admissible in court like one of the big
thing that's going to happen I have
already witnessed this courts have
admitted fake AI generated images we saw
it with Kyle Rittenhouse but I can tell
you about other court cases definitively
that have said they absolutely will
admit deep fake videos and it is the
responsibility of of the person
disputing it to prove it's not real
that's what the courts are saying right
now man people put a lot of faith in the
intelligence of uh the authority and not
necessarily intelligent people well
that's going to be wild the idea that
the burden has to be on you to prove
these things wrong we were talking about
this with another guest who suggested
there's gonna have to be an entire New
Field of forensics that builds it's not
possible these things it but I think in
the long run well I mean yeah but that's
the point I'm making is I think in the
long run it it might become impossible
the technology will get so good that you
can't investigate these things it's
impossible now the the remedy for
someone introducing deep fakes to court
is for you to bring an expert in so what
happens is let's say you have an act you
have actual video evidence of uh Donald
Trump doing a backflip and you're in
corn you say your honor Trump did the
backflip here's the video and Trump goes
it's that real it's a fake video and
then Trump's team just goes to an expert
and says is it real and they go yeah
that's real okay next expert Is that
real yeah that's real next expert Is
that real how much you gonna pay me we
what's your rate five thousand dollars a
day we'll pay you that it's fake come on
down to Chinatown they bring him to the
courtroom and then he says it's fake
what's extra unnerving to this too is
that it'll bring all photos and videos
even of the past into question yep it's
like and then there's going to be
revisionist history for everything and
it's going to be very bad this is the
door right now images of Donald Trump
hugging Dr fauci and if you take a look
at them if they only used the one on the
bottom right that they would have gotten
away with it the one in the middle and
the bottom where Trump has his arms
around him and he's holding his fist is
very strange the top left with mehap
whims in the in the White House emblem
clearly fake the one in the bottom right
you can't really tell except for the
textures and someone might say no that's
real they could argue that they made the
mistake of using three which with one
being discernably fake which then
provides evidence the other ones are
likely fake too seriously though men
from a distance they all look real this
all looks real to me now imagine you're
you imagine you're in an airport and
this ad runs on the TV or a news outlet
covers the end says take a look at this
ad run by campaign and then you see on a
grainy television far away Trump hugging
DeSantis that's the point hugging to
santus
this campaign releases forgiveness
Donald Trump endorses us he wants you to
vote for us instead
that could be like people are you
allowed to make claims about what other
people said and did that they didn't do
that's where we're going but it's been
two years I don't I don't get did they
have some kind of polling we don't have
these these so he gave him another hug
is it really gonna boost the scientists
well I I'm not Trump I know like a
quarter like quarter to a third of
Trump's base those die hards absolutely
hate the vaccine stuff and hate the
fouchy stuff hate all the lockdown
operation warp speed think all that
stuff is super toxic and I do think it
was a potent message the more he brought
it up but now over playing his hand kind
of ruins it exactly like like when TR
you know he can bring this up and he can
say you didn't fire Fouch you pushed the
vaccines oh did I kiss him by the nose
run really like him a big bear hug and
kiss him out of the nose this man's
ridiculous right just easy why
exaggerate if the truth is already bad
enough even focus on operation warp
speed because a lot of trump supporters
are really against that but like to do
something so stupid again that's why I
said the not intelligent Vibe I get from
him or that he's surrounded himself with
really poorly educated like people that
just don't get it because why would you
do that why would you sabotage yourself
when your enemy is making a mistake it's
like the oldest Art of War obviously
someone someone just pointed something
out the the bottom image with Trump
hugging fauci is actually look it's a
Photoshop from when he hugged the flag
so you know you know the you remember
the picture of trump hugging the flag
yeah yeah it does look like that I'm not
100 sure but that's kind of how the AI
also takes things yeah yeah yep
so where where this goes we are going to
video and photos
and what can you do about it I know
that's why I think it's so important to
call this out and say no to it because
if and this and this is why I'm like the
DeSantis supporters are doing everything
their power to hurt Ron DeSantis because
there's no excuse for making a fake
using fake images to smear a political
opponent right now we know how dangerous
the AI stuff is going to be we need to
put a hard Line in the Sand right now
and say we will not tolerate this in any
capacity and the Santa supporters are
like no it's fine and you know it's
actually because because Trump posted
these funny images and this is okay I
could also see this technology
increasing the demand for a surveillance
State because people could say things
like well look if you have the GPS chip
on your phone tracking you at all time
you can actually confirm where you were
at any given date and time and so you
could debunk certain deep fakes with
that information
uh more like more more July I wonder
accountability well not so much that is
as much as I'm saying like I think
because of uh the Deep fake technology
people who are very concerned about
being deep faked could turn to other
methods of documenting their life that
we currently consider invasive like
having your smartphone track you
everywhere you are all the time and then
deliver the data to you or to some
larger database that could confirm that
you really were there something like
that better way would be to put the onus
of proof on the person that's offering
the image or the video I think the
solution to this I would agree to be a
ton more media literacy in the public
and you will not be you're gonna have to
not believe literally a single thing a
video or picture that you see on the
internet and you will have to question
it I am not 100 sure this is real and
it's sad because the media literacy in
our public is already very low Twitter
is not helping but it's going to be
crucial moving forward as we're seeing
Ai and disinformation and misinformation
In the Flesh actually exists you got to
wonder if you know five ten years from
now people see these things and they say
do you see the footage of him doing that
oh yeah that's just a video you know
it's just video footage whatever I think
it's easily faked I think we're going
back to uh the Dark Ages in a sense
there was a time period where we did not
know what was going on 100 200 years ago
you're living on a farm and then the
newspaper man comes to town and you go
how about the newspaper sooner and then
they they all get together and then he's
like I got the paper here's what's
happening in New York and you're like
wow and that was a month ago it's funny
like a month ago a ship came and it
carried a bunch of Ivory and they're
like wow they called it the Dark Ages
but it was really like the blind age is
like too much light will blind you and
you may as well be dark because you
can't see anything that's exactly what
yeah exactly it we're entering a period
where it's we can call it the light ages
where there's so much information we're
blinded by it and we can't see what's
going on
soon enough the only place you'll be
able to know things are real from is Tim
cast news that's right that's the only
way yeah
you don't want to say we can't be deep
faked
[Laughter]
yeah
Sheamus is actually not a real person
I'm not even real yeah
I remember you being a potato that's
extremely offensive um firstly you're
gonna hear from my lawyer the reason the
reason he was off the show for so long
was because the computer that generates
his voice and images broken it broke
down yeah I accidentally I accidentally
uh poured some coke it's powered by a
potato I feel like asking people not to
use this technology is like asking
people not to use the newest weapon that
was developed exactly and it's not who
the hell like maybe you can get a
non-proliferation treaty for all the
weaker countries around Earth but the
big superpowers are definitely gonna
Technology's inevitable you can't stop
it well yeah because I I remember there
was uh some talk of I think Elon Musk
was talking about this a few months ago
a bunch of people signing an agreement
to stop or slow down the development of
AI okay well let's see if China agrees
to that let's see if Russia agrees that
let's see if like any other
technological Powers willing to hold off
on the development of this unbelievably
profitable and Powerful technology see
if open AI agrees to it a decade ago we
were having the same conversation about
genetic engineering and like how we
should stop look researching it and then
but nobody nobody across the world was
going to get on board with that and I
don't believe the solution is trying to
stop the advancement of the technology
you can just use it better than anyone
else well if we stop doing it China's
not going to stop so we need to figure
out the correct way to use it and like
uh in the genetic engineering
conversation is like finding the right
way to attack and defend against
diseases that are potentially made in
the future
you gotta gain a function look where
genetic engineering is yeah I mean
that's a whole big yeah without you I
can't believe uh Trump didn't fire him
out here yeah turn it around
operation warp speed no I look I agree
with you on both of those things when
you guys are doing publicity Adam do you
do like uh like ethics are they involved
do you have to account for ethics or do
you just whatever you have to do to get
it done like is it about winning or is
it about doing what's right like how do
you how do you play I mean you always
got to do what's right
but there's you know you can play the
little publicity stunts here and there
that makes sense but you got to play by
the rules right you gotta I would have
said don't do this it's a fake you can't
just put out fake photos like that's
when you're wrong the United States and
you're the second you know the right
behind Trump the runner-up it's it's
risk versus reward you know you're
you're you're betting on the loser horse
it's like we're gonna we're gonna make
this thing and what we can gain from it
is minimal and what we can lose from it
is everything well and you know you made
the point that some of these images are
fake but we wouldn't be able to tell it
would have been much more difficult to
tell at the very least if we didn't have
the picture with lettering behind it
that was so over the top with him smooch
and fouchy uh and you gotta Wonder are
there other instances of deep fakes
being out there in political campaigns
being used that we just haven't picked
up on because they weren't as ridiculous
you guys think
I think it went under the radar I think
he slowly Stafford I think it's possible
he signed off but signed off on it but
like he's sitting in his office type on
a computer and they pull up an iPad and
they hold it up to him and say Here's
the ad and he's sitting there and you
watch it and he goes it's great run it
and anyway guys what we're talking about
so the buck stops with him definitely
but I don't I don't I don't think he
knew they ran deep big images I'm saying
like if he approved of it he looked at
it didn't realize what it was and said
looks good
The Descendants campaign is 100 correct
to criticize Trump on fauci and Berks
this ruined it for them literally this
morning I'm like DeSantis has given us
everything we've asked for in Florida
he's he's been leading so well he does
let Charisma but Trump really does have
a weakness when it comes to fauci Dr
Burks and the cover response and that's
where they can go after him and then all
of a sudden I see this this news and I'm
like holy crap did they really screw
this one up and then instead of being
like we disavow we apologize we don't
know how this got out they the the
supporters all run out full speed and
say we are allowed to do it and I'm like
okay DeSantis supporters are some of the
nastiest people online nasty Trump's got
nasty people don't get me wrong but the
fact that they will defend anything and
you've got people tweeting at me being
like why aren't you criticizing Trump
and I'm like I'm sorry I didn't realize
that because Trump was was a dick that
means descent is allowed to do things
that are wrong so and that's the best
they could offer well what about Trump
what about him are you gonna say that
descendants can do this because Trump's
bad too great I'll vote for the
libertarian party I don't need either of
them
that's where we're going Dave Smith yeah
I went down in 2000 yeah Dave Smith in
2000 November 2020 I had to get the hell
out of New York lockdowns you can't go
to a restaurant you can't go to a gym I
said I'm getting went down to visit a
client he was having a party in his
townhouse in Miami Beach I said I'm
coming here right and DeSantis did a
great job for two years I even went to a
fundraise that I Trump did for him is it
was about in uh September of 2020 so and
Trump and then I was trying to be
charismatic with DeSantis but it's very
hard he's doesn't know any of the
personality Trump has and it was stuck
out to me I said I just got down here I
had to get out of New York and I
couldn't get any personality out of him
and I was with my dad he's 85 at the
time and he says is that your dad Trump
says that you get him over here
and I says I'm thinking back I says
that's the difference you know Trump's
personality he knows what's in a room
and he can work a room it doesn't matter
but DeSantis I don't think this was his
time you really shouldn't someone uh
super chatted us and said that Donald
Trump is actually a DJ he's DJ Trump
yeah
literally like oh yeah that's kind of
funny he's a people person that's that's
a big president too Larger than Life
personality you were at the social media
Summit yeah the White House doing it
three years ago yeah it's only three
years ago Trump was doing a stand-up
routine yeah we're sitting there and I'm
like I have no idea what this is we're
in I thought it was gonna be like a
round table with a small group of people
and then we sit down there's chairs
lining up from a Podium and Trump just
does stand up and we were all laughing
our asses off and I was like what the is
it funny I don't know what's going on
but it's hilarious I thought we were
gonna get away with no mudslinging man
and this is typical truck because after
Trump won remember he said everybody
want to come in the garden with me
afterwards you just invited
he was doing a presser with uh uh just
uh attorney general Barr and then some
of the influences got in it with CNN and
uh a couple of the reporters oh that was
funny yeah the there was like a fight
broke out or something right it was I
think it was Brian it's the guy who went
to Playboy the Playboy White House
correspondent only under Trump oh god
with Gorka Gorka guided it with the
Playboy I can't remember his name but he
was the Playboy White House
correspondent
only at the Trump that he made all these
irrelevant uh White House Correspondents
famous yeah yeah that they got book
deals and everything that's why he they
want him back in office that's why
they're trying to push these indictments
and all that Sheamus is waiting
patiently to dive behind you and I think
something that you hit spot on is about
uh the lack of Charisma for from
DeSantis so last week um for Tim cast
news I covered all of his stops in New
Hampshire
um he kind of gave the same speech four
different times but he really isn't
personable
um lacks like that natural Charisma and
really comes off kind of smug and rigid
um or at least that was my impression I
also feel as though he tries to play off
as though he's not an elitist although
he still has gone to these prestigious
colleges I believe at least Yale but
maybe also Harvard so so when Ron comes
on the show and it's going to be hot you
better look at me in the eyes and be
like not intelligent huh and then look
at Tim and be like so no Charisma you
better call us on this stuff because
this is what the conversation's about if
you're really gonna be about president
then we gotta we gotta air it out well I
just look man when I I brought up the
Jazz Jennings thing
the DeSantis Pasha and Redfern started
tweeting at me calling me a grifter and
insulting me for simply pointing out
that jazz Jennings lives in Florida and
these horrible things are happening
and I was like why why are you yelling
at me like what what is what is with
these people
they're very defensive over him his his
online team if he's got a firearm these
are terrible people they're like they're
destroying his campaign yeah they'll
come after you after you like dogs if
they perceive an attack like that as an
attack although it wasn't you know what
the best thing they could have done
would be literally say nothing you know
the second best thing they could have
done if they had to do something say Tim
we are on it with a winky winky emoji
and then I would be like oh look at that
does Santa's campaign knows they're
doing something and they could have done
nothing they could have just posted that
and it would have been that's the end of
it instead they decided to go to war and
create a conflict that creates negative
attention around DeSantis and led to the
confirmation that jazz Jennings received
gender surgery in Florida under the rule
of Ron DeSantis as Rana cedis was
governor Jazz did receive surgery and so
they want to play this game like Ron
doesn't have a time machine well now you
open the door and now we know that's
that it was under run so I think what
you you were making that point even that
everything Ron did was was safe
was it just in general like did you say
that that uh maybe he was doing things
that were like just in line with the
acceptable culture War right I don't
know if I was making that point hard but
I do believe that he's he's a very play
it safe kind of guy which concerns me
he'll get co-opted by the bureaucracy or
already has been like I don't see him
being being willing to go off script
that's good get off the script dude I
think what you wrote down I think he's
got to fire these people he's got a he
has to fire them because they are really
really bad at what they do I think he's
trying really hard to beat Trump on
policy but is forgetting that most
people actually do not care much at all
about policy that's not what's getting
somebody to vote for you or not when
he's trying to hit on Trump on abortion
like Sheamus doesn't care Sheamus still
supports Trump although I I actually
that's one of the things I I'm not uh in
an entirely committed position I think
it depends on what their stances end up
being I prefer Trump as a candidate uh
in a lot of ways but I'm I'm always
voting so here's the thing you prefer
prefer Trump right now although he is
more pro-choice than DeSantis well if
we're talking about who's more likely to
win a federal election I think
especially if Trump's position were to
change to a more pro-life position it
wouldn't even be a question for me but
if we're talking about who's more
charismatic who's probably more likely
to carry voters yeah I think Trump there
was also some talk behind the scenes and
there was a leak from desantis's
campaign that suggested he might not
hold to as strong a pro-life I'm not
sure if we can find them
so maybe that doesn't mean anything
DeSantis is trying to hit him from the
right but most people seem to not even
care as they should or at just how
politics plays out so Ron's biggest
strength is to just say I'm just like
Trump but I'm calm
yeah I mean all their personalities
policies ideology pretty much the same
90 it's how did Trump conquer and become
the person his personality is larger in
life he's funny he's engaging he's you
know what New York style responsible on
the issues though and you know he's
pragmatic at times and and I think Tim
has a great Point Ron should be the
comma Trump yep you know somewhat like a
Ronald Reagan mode our policies are the
same he did a great job but we need to
cut we need to have a combination at the
moment we need to bring in moderates we
need to win the middle and that's but
Ron's best play not the bitter bitter
back and forth and that's not the way to
do you cannot get a win back and forth
with Trump there's no way Trump's
probably one of the least right-wing
candidates though in the Republicans
and he slayed brilliant candidates okay
marriage yeah yeah exactly relatively
loose on abortion at this point
relatively compared to compared to like
compared to DeSantis agreed among other
things so yeah I think no I think
there's a lot of positions where Trump
could and should be better there's
absolutely no disability that's why this
is so difficult trying to win on policy
you're not going to beat Trump on policy
by trying to hit him from the right
that's been desantis's play here he's
thinking of it too much like a
politician that's not how Trump won
Trump didn't win based on I want to
clarify too like I am not saying the
President should be calm I'm saying the
selling point to status has is that he
is like Trump but calm because there are
a lot of moderates and independents that
think Trump is too over the top my purse
personal view we need Trump to go in
like a bull in a china shop and fire all
these people yeah and so there have been
a number of things that like on the
abortion messaging where I think Trump
has been entirely wrong I'd like to see
him uh shift there absolutely I do in
that sense very much prefer DeSantis is
stance he's pro-life and and when it
comes to the primary I'm always going to
vote for the most pro-life candidate but
part of my critique of DeSantis has also
been the fact that he lacks Charisma and
a lot of Die Hard supporters get upset
with me for saying that but you're not
helping him or his campaign by not
addressing so respectfully if DeSantis
is more pro-life than Donald Trump why
don't you support DeSantis over Trump I
think well so I think as a candidate
DeSantis is less charismatic I'm not
saying that I would definitively support
um Trump over DeSantis in the primary
without any qualification there I think
if Trump moved to a more pro-life stance
I absolutely would and I also think that
if DeSantis became more charismatic and
was more pragmatic candidate on the
national stage that would help
blame the midterm losses from
Republicans on the abortion and I
discussed that on my podcast with Lila
Rose I think that's a massive failure on
his parties came out saying six weeks
Trump was still like Trump said that he
called it cruel yeah which I think was
horrible messaging and I think it's
entirely wrong yeah so but it still
doesn't get you really it doesn't matter
to you no I never said that no I never
said that I never said it doesn't matter
to me I said that DeSantis needs to work
on his Charisma I think we're trumped in
and I would also and this is why I'm
saying as of now because
I think it's possible Trump moves on
that issue as you've mentioned Trump is
very flexible and he's been in different
positions and adopted different
positions over time I would say that
when it comes to DeSantis building up
his Charisma making that statement isn't
saying that I'm now a die-hard trump
supporter who will never like the Santos
it's simply saying that I think he needs
to fix that problem to be a more
palatable candidate yeah that's all
DeSantis will not beat Trump from a
policy even though he might be better on
policy that's not how he's going to beat
him oh no I agree well and this is the
thing so I was in and I was getting into
so many arguments with people about this
because I was saying
DeSantis needs to work up his Charisma
he needs to get better at this and they
were saying oh like Charisma matters
people should vote on policy agreed
people should vote on policy they're
probably not going to right they never
do and so you and so that's my point
where I and I said this so many times I
think that um I think that a stronger
DeSantis is better for America overall
regardless who ends up getting the
nomination regardless of who ends up
winning I think it is better for America
for both of these men to be as strong as
they can be and to be as effective as
they can be in one of the areas where
DeSantis lacks Effectiveness is his
Charisma yeah you need a Mattingly you
don't need one but you will benefit
severely from a charismatic military
commander he's the commander of the
military if you if the troops believe in
you they'll fight and die for you if
they don't they're gonna quit look at
our military right now Joe Biden
frailing around it's a it's a travesty
yeah I like that description
and this lack of charisma at least at
least Trump is charismatic whether you
like him or not doesn't matter you can
have high Charisma and be unliked it
doesn't mean people are gonna like you
so this is also like can I just oh sorry
call for DeSantis to get in here and we
all have to twit you know work on his
personality a bit right hell yes dude
let's talk about mushrooms man let's get
real we talked about things that people
really care about we need it we talked
about this a bit when he announced that
I can't believe they looked at that
announcement video that he posted on
Twitter and and they were like this is
good I can't believe they did not have
someone at the level there at the the
they're in second place right now in the
Republican primary for the presidency of
the United States and they couldn't get
someone to come and look at that video
and be like guys you need more energy
whatever you got to do to get more
energy in there have an eagle fly over I
don't know what it is but Ron walking up
and being like freedom is worth fighting
for was just watch Barack Obama announce
he did it he's in front of all these
people he's got a huge crowd and he does
that thing where he pauses what he's
saying very slowly and elevates his
voice that's why I Barack Obama I'm
announcing well in the crowds are
screaming and there's all that energy
and you watch that video and you're like
wow people are getting fired up then you
go in the Twitter space and Ron's like
well I'm here to lead the American
comeback and you're like okay
you know who was Ronald Reagan's
brilliant with visuals Bill Clinton was
brilliant with visuals Rhonda Sanders
lost the simple rule of politics visuals
are very important he announced on
Twitter did we have any visuals none
zero you can never revisit that moment
right so you got one shot to announce
right the one day and he should have
been in one of the counties that he did
such tremendous job in Florida he's got
a great story to tell and he should know
his supporters his family his wife it's
up there and that would have been an
amazing announcement he could if he
could have gotten like a a giant drone
you see those drones that people ride
the big ones he could have landed
look I'm I'm half kidding but he could
have done anything to generate spectacle
to cause his mat yeah right he's
standing he's standing on like the like
a quadcopter as it lands and then he
jumps off and walks to the party in
front of a huge crowd zipline yeah
exactly exactly something is super so
superficial but if you could pull up him
smiling Ron DeSantis has a horrible
smile if if you seriously could he said
he was sending out like emails of him
smiling it's just like he's that's one
of the biggest things like yeah somebody
looks like he's in pain they I don't
think these are good smiles and
um you know I don't know we are a
superficial people I disagree you don't
think he all right that's a really good
smile on the right yeah that's that's
the run I want to see the one thing you
know what I I yeah
he's probably a really cool guy I bet he
I bet he's like a really likable guy you
don't get to become governor if you're
not well Katie Hopkins someone needs to
take this picture right here John
fetterman's a senator yeah Johnson
someone needs to take this and then
yeah yeah man like easy to throw stones
from the sidelines Ron so the the Deep
fake thing for me is hard no unless he
comes out and fires somebody someone
substantial and says we disavow this
what here's what's gonna happen his PR
people are gonna say don't address it at
all don't say anything let it go away
it's unacceptable so if he doesn't I'm
not I'm not going anywhere near I will
not support a campaign that
intentionally is making fake images to
lie I can't like look man I know it's
politics people lie but this is a Step
Beyond it's one thing to mischaracterize
it's another thing like like Trump posts
these people people keep asking about
Trump re-truth thing that image where
it's allegedly descendants with young
girls and he's trying to imply that his
antis is like a pedo or a groom or
whatever and I'm like yeah that's very
bad I do not like those things Trump
gets no credit from me from that but
Trump re-truthing someone and being a
dick is very different from your
campaign running an ad where you made
fake images or where you have you have
plays I don't know who made them but you
placed fake images to smear this sounds
really concerning because you could deep
fake Ron with getting a back massage
from his wife's sister and like be like
it looks real like it's like and then
that shows division within his family
like it's so dark this path man because
this opens a Pandora's box right do we
gonna have to live through this week
after week after week yeah yep so we
can't the technology is moving too fast
No One's Gonna back down so right now
with the AI stuff you've got people
begging these companies to stop we are
going to die you need to stop this they
can't stop because these you get one
company saying guys
we'll do it right but if we don't do it
the other company will so no matter what
you say you've got 10 companies 20 30 40
50 all full steam ahead on launching
this AI stuff and no one will battle yes
Sam Altman CEO of open AI who's like one
of the companies leading the charge of
the AI is uh went on uh Lex Friedman's
podcast and asked Lex to his face should
we open source this and Lex went no I
don't think so and I was like what in
the hell are you guys talking about
you're like supposed to be the thought
leaders and you don't want it open
because you're afraid that someone else
is going to take it and make it make it
better than you if you want to make it
secret so that the AI takes over like
what come on it was supposed to be open
source that's what's called open AI it's
called open and it's closed what the
hell are you doing Sam well uh Elon
talked about that didn't he contribute a
large sum of money and then they took
the money and then turned into a private
corporation like god dude it's cyber
dime this is like how the Terminator got
built in Terminator 2 man you take some
proprietary AI company it spins out of
control and then the machine goes Rogue
like so the way the AI destroys all of
us is not the way people think it's
going to be it's not going to be
Terminators being like humans are the
threat it's going to be something
ridiculous like there's that story where
they claimed and apparently it's not
true they claimed that they programmed a
drone they gave it an AI to fly and blow
up certain targets and then it earned
points when it when it hit the target
in the simulation It could only attack
the target if it got approval from the
operator it then realized the operator
saying no was detrimental to it getting
points so it blew up the operator then
they said okay blowing up the operator
gives you minus points so it stopped
doing that so then it blew up the
communication Towers apparently they say
the story is not true or something about
it is fabricated but the general concept
of it is exactly what happens with AI
and why it will go bad we will make an
AI and we will ask to do something
simple we'll make Finance Ai and we'll
be like hey make these trade stocks so
that we can boost our 401k and you earn
the AI earns points when people's
returns improve what will end up
happening is it will do something
totally unexpected and weird to earn
points like shorting a bunch of vital
stocks destroying the economy and then
one day people wake up and they have no
savings but one guy's got 78 30 you know
365 trillion dollars in his account he
doesn't know how and it's like I
maximized my points then the system
completely breaks because of it yeah or
you reduce the population and then you
have a relatively larger number of
people that are wealthy so like you yep
if we told an AI to do finance and we
said you your goal is to make as much
money as possible for the people who
have invested in these specific you know
efts or
um you know these Ira whatever these
stocks these this portfolio
it will say
if if we have one million people and one
million dollars in the market each
person gets one dollar if we eliminate
half of those people Everyone now has
two dollars one of the strategies
towards maximizing returns might be to
literally destroy companies through
finance that produce food and medicine
so that people die resulting in more of
the existing wealth the money may become
worthless because there's no people to
do work but all that matters is that
number to the end you hope that an AI is
intelligent enough to know what
collateral damage it could cause but I
don't think anything is that perfect
look at what happened with YouTube
YouTube said we we want to compete with
Netflix so we're going to make an
algorithm that promotes long-form videos
that people watch for a longer amount of
time they thought they would get Game of
Thrones they say people watch Game of
Thrones for an hour so we want content
that's at least an hour that people will
at least watch most of what did they get
they started getting one podcasts which
is okay but they started getting a lot
of really freaky content of Rand of
Hitler dancing with the incredible hold
and stuff like that Spider-Man and Elsa
doing gross for 40 minutes yeah yeah
injections huge a lot of a lot of
injection porn I remember uh people yeah
people getting injections like that's a
prime for the whole covet narrative too
it was crazy sorry well no no I was just
saying that I know people I know people
with kids who are like oh my gosh my my
daughter was watching YouTube and this
thing popped up basically instructing
the child on how to do something like
very violent and they're like what is
going on and then I believe that's when
YouTube ended up enabling the kids mode
so even that didn't change it there were
a bunch of videos where the thumbnails
were children it was cartoons of kids
drinking out of urinals and toilets and
eating feces and things like that the AI
was making these things people people
had AI programs that would Auto generate
it would make videos and upload them to
YouTube to get traffic and make money
and then it would keep trying to
maximize views and revenue and that's
what made more money for it it's
important to remember we're not just
intelligence like it's part of how we
make our decisions but emotions is a
huge part and machines don't have
emotions at this stage of development I
don't know if they ever really will but
you know what they're programmed by
really emotional people it's the thing
right for now yeah yeah then they may
start getting programmed by other AI
with no emotions at all but then those
well like because when you look at what
chat GPT will and won't say a lot of
it's not logical right it's like based
on somebody's emotional sensibilities
that have like chat GPT program
something then it's programming that
thing based on the emotional
sensibilities that we're put into it
you've got to know when your orders are
are uh wrong yeah when the orders are
are bad and you've got to say no to the
orders you've got to know that but
that's an emotional ability I don't
think that like you know obviously the
logic dictates ripping human bodies open
to study the heart will make us better
at becoming heart doctors but that
doesn't mean you want to rip human
bodies open all the time but they study
Hearts the AI has no conscience or moral
framework so it will just say to better
understand heart open human yeah unless
if that's not programmed into it ability
of it you just go there you know learn
about Hearts here's how you tear a
person oh you guys at all think the any
of this AI stuff is overhyped garbage
that the media likes to scare manga
around
not at all no I've been here
is all reluctant to make predictions
about it because of that I don't know I
mean I think almost any prediction
anyone makes about AI is going to age
really poorly yeah the media I would say
generally hasn't been talking much about
it at all which is why I don't I don't
feel like that I'm actually scared
because we talk about it and every time
we talk about it have these
contingencies of more possible I think
the media talks about it a lot and then
you have like these stories of like the
Godfather of AI saying that Doom is near
because of this but I feel like we're
calling it AI but it's not exactly that
it's like a language model that is
predicting the next word so there's
nothing inherently original or
thoughtful in what it's producing yeah
and like the pictures work by just
mushing stuff together so there's
nothing again like true but you're
referring specifically to language
models when I talk about like earning
points to develop models they have they
have the dog robot that you've probably
seen they programmed it to learn how to
do its stuff on it like to learn how to
walk on its own and then they left it in
a room and just it just figured out how
to eventually walk I think you're right
that a lot of what we're calling
artificial intelligence right now is
large language models llm large language
models and that Sam Altman was
predicting that he's the CEO of open air
that by September of this year 2023 we
will have our first general intelligence
which is where it can create more of it
yeah and I'm fully willing to be wrong
in the ways this will impact our economy
and jobs is going to be crazy and
interesting and I don't know maybe not
fun to see but well look I can already
tell you right I can already tell you as
somebody who like owns a business that
creates and markets artistic products
like we do the cartoons for the YouTube
channel there's also clients we service
there are ways that I can see uh this
stuff really changing our industry
absolutely you could replace all the
animators well I wouldn't want to but
hypothetically if it got to that point I
think that's a possibility for a lot of
Studios or didn't you could end up
didn't we already use mid-journey to
make Freedom Tunes no we tried it it was
it looked very weird but it was like but
you could so here's the thing there are
certain things and I attempted to do
this I was using mid-journey what is
majority for people who don't oh sure
it's it's uh probably the best available
AI for generating images they look very
realistic they are extremely compelling
and highly intricate and you go to their
Discord you sign up on their website
then you go to Discord you type backs or
forward slash imagine and then it gives
you a prompt and you can type in
whatever you want and well and so I was
curious I wanted to see like you know do
a background in this animated art style
or that animated art style and you end
up with something that you know still
looks a little wonky still looks a
little bit off it's not perfect one
thing I was thinking of in terms of
practical application is you know maybe
you could use something like this to
just color your images in right so
instead of drawing on the computer then
coloring maybe you can actually go back
to pencil and paper and do frame by
frame and just put each image into your
computer and tell the AI hey like color
this uh in Flash it out there are ways
you can still be very involved in the
artistic process in utilize AI
potentially in in the coming years and I
think that's sort of the ideal situation
where you still have real artists making
these things but they're able to make
something so much more visually
interesting and intricate because the
computer technology is assisting using
it as a tool yeah well and so I've
mentioned this before
what we do at Freedom Tunes would be
literally impossible without computer
animation right doing a hand-drawn like
two to five minute long video once a
week sometimes three to four times a
week it it literally wouldn't be
possible without computer animation and
that also means that what I'm doing
requires fewer animators than it would
have required 15 years ago 20 years ago
30 years ago before this stuff was
common so yeah like it might limit the
number of jobs but the people who have
those jobs will probably be able to do a
lot more it's an interesting perspective
on it with how computers also help you
make the cartoons and AI will help you
do them in a different way potentially
and if you can please the AI the AI will
reward you like your viewers become AI
itself and the more of the AI you can
impress the more you will be rewarded in
the long run interesting I mean well I I
was just kind of kind of add that or AI
white well AI wife AI family well I mean
I was I was just gonna say that you know
people might look at the situation and
they say well you know this guy's making
several cartoons a week for for his
business and he's got a you know
talented team of employees who he's
working with on this but you know if he
was doing this 30 years ago there there
could have been dozens or hundreds of
people many more people with jobs no no
if it was if it was 30 years ago it just
wouldn't exist right it just wouldn't
exist it wouldn't be possible so I think
instead of seeing it as something that's
going to limit job potential it's
important also conceive of the fact that
it's going to create Industries like
things will be possible that we're not
we're gonna go to super chats so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
click join us because we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show coming up
for you in about a half an hour and it's
going to be fun and spicy don't bring
the kids all right I'm not your buddy
guy says as a Canadian I find it rather
offensive that you think our crazy
lefties don't know how to use cell
phones and yet think space lasers are
just as likely by the way where did you
get the laser idea from uh I never said
it was likely that laser started fires I
said it was actually practically
impossible but at least somewhat in the
realm of possibilities and and the idea
that 400 well I said 140 140 lefties all
went to key locations hundreds of miles
apart and then timed ignition of fires
that's just ridiculous I'm sorry it's
not what happened could have been a
controlled burn and now they're saying
this 450 fires in Canada yeah I'm sorry
I just Google the satellite image you
see how they all started or a bunch of
them start around the same moment that's
not true because you're watching a time
lapse yeah this is the other thing
people did they took a Time Lapse video
of several hours and then because the
fires start within a few hours of each
other not at the same time it looks like
they all start at the same time that was
me that brought up space lasers and it
was that I thought it would be more
likely that someone you lit him with
space lasers than that God itself lit
the fire here's the other thing about
that satellite imagery showing all the
smoke it's actually the fire starting
the smoke is rising straight up and you
don't see it until the wind current
pushes the smoke down so okay so the
wind could have inflamed it and then you
see it all the same moment because
that's when the winds came through if
the currents are slow are are not moving
very fast you won't see smoke spreading
very far and then when the current comes
in all the smoke moves at once and
people are like whoa all the fire
started at once Ian why is it more
likely that it was started by a space
laser than God because fires are natural
like forest fires they happen all the
time there was a major lightning storm
like why would it happen all the time
why we always got to blame somebody
that's what we're talking about last
night like the flood God did it like why
we gotta blame that blamed on climate
change
climate change protest today outside of
the White House they were blaming like
floods and this fire in particular
um on climate change so yeah it's it's
pretty wild and they're so smug in their
certainty that this was caused by
climate change let's just say let's say
man-made catastrophic climate change is
happening in the world is going to end
in in 12 years and then 12 years from
now you know you can say that all over
again let's just say that that's the
case and all that's true
maybe one forest fire could actually not
be climate change right
itself doesn't do things it's what is
the thing that happened that is a change
and let's talk about the thing itself
then that could have caused it but
change it climate change is not like a a
cause it's interesting what's changing
let's read some more we got Raymond g
Stanley Jr he says Tim I also think a
part that plays into the more
conservative poll numbers are people
like myself 2019 I wasn't a Politico
whereas today I'm all about you that
forward the line stance here here so uh
Gallup shows that all age groups have
shifted more conservative the big shift
uh I think the big shift is 30 to 44 but
there is a prominent shift 18 to 29
towards conservative to a certain degree
and now more people in the US identify
as conservative than anything else well
it's interesting though because what it
means to be conservative has changed so
much right so 10 15 years ago uh knowing
the differences between boys and girls
just made you a mentally confident an
adult and if you couldn't answer the
question what is a woman people would
assume that you weren't fit to function
in society nowadays if you do know the
answer to that question you're not only
conservative you're a far-right
extremist I just hate Communists yeah
you know communism is very bad
ideology sometimes Communists can be
pretty cool actually that's a fair point
I tell the story a lot there was a guy I
met in Berkeley who had the sickle and
Hammer and he was had books that he was
like giving books out and stuff and
talking to people wearing a mask and I
walked up to him and I was just like
what do you think about antifa and he
was like what do you mean and I was like
those guys over there they're beating
people he's like that's wrong they
shouldn't do that and I was like I agree
and I shook his hand and he was like
he's like my ideas are about how we all
live together peacefully and no one
should be attacking anybody else and I'm
like I prefer they agreed with you a
rare Noble communist yeah I think these
are a few in between yeah it's not a
political government it's not a
functional government structure it's
it's cool in a family it's a Ponzi
scheme well but even that though like
because people say that but really
What communists are doing is they're
they're taking Behavior that's like
appropriate at the family level and then
they're saying let's destroy the family
and have the government do this instead
what yeah I gotta read this one it's it
seemingly starts off silly but I think
it's really mean but I'm gonna read it
anyway Mark giadetti says I thought
illad changed his name to John Bolton Jr
Ian is neither a wizard or a shaman he
is just an egotistical sophist
I mean you see what you are you know
but uh is it the mustache that makes
people think you're like John Bolton
because it is a beautiful muscle I also
say I like uh how Trump bombed suleimani
and stuff like that so yeah John
Blankenship says things yeah
and the drone strikes earlier I don't
know should Obama been indicted for it
anyway yeah John Blankenship says what
if one of the bribes Biden received was
the Corvette
ah
T-Rex Pet Shop says has anybody else
noticed that many other huge companies
like Family Dollar didn't even put out
their pride stuff this year maybe
they're scared of the backlash keep it
the pressure especially on woke pet
stores like PetSmart Chewie and Petco
just shop at T-Rex Pet Shop instead
much better options
they uh anybody you know what just we
got to tell the Public Square guys to
just make like a list of companies that
have published publicly said communism
is not good just very it is not okay to
be a communist can we can we print those
out yeah it is not okay to be communist
but a community is everything communism
is wrong it's wrong if you do that the
media report far right extremists
everywhere communism no you know and I'm
not a shaman or a wizard either that's
true good point I'm just a guy dude I
left Miami I'm heading up to New York I
don't know how in in data I'm going to
be with pride once I stroll into New
York City
when you breathe in the air you will
become every store Rockefeller store all
the flags are Pride Flags now it's
supposed to be the flags of the world or
whatever you know when I first moved to
the Village it was Pride day at the end
of June now they have to have ever now
they have to have 30 days the whole
month and it seems like it seems like
it's every month
that's what I care about here's a good
one Jason Hutchinson says if we're
locking up former presidents I've got a
list exactly exactly
Leon Yoder says Vivek ramaswamy just
tweeted that he would pardon Trump if
elected this double standard of justice
is going to destroy our society I
applaud Vivek for doing this and hope
all of the Republican candidates follow
his lead
I I think if there is a debate it's
going to be Trump and Vivek that's it
nobody else on stage will matter Vivek
knows what people want to hear and he
will tell them it
you don't trust him I that's all I mean
I don't trust anybody but you don't
believe him I think he is acting closely
and when he he thinks he could say
something to help Advance his space in
like the mega subcategory that I think
he's going after then he goes for it but
I don't I I disagree in the sense that I
do think he knows what people want to
hear but I don't think that's his
motivation he's he sat down with me and
he said there should be some kind of
Civic requirement for voting and I'm
like that's a bold thing to say because
that's like that's good that causes
damage politically among younger voters
he was like we got to do it something
cynical about me just sees him as an
opportunist I don't know why he is you
know it's agile he'll change his
thoughts CEO he did a lot of business
stuff and then he wrote a book and
everything and the reason why they came
to him and said you need to put up a
picture on your Instagram or whatever
with the black Square because of George
Floyd and he was like oh okay sure I
guess then they came to him and they
said no we want you to write a statement
where the company supports this and he
was like oh all right I guess and then
he wrote something where he said I hope
this country can heal and come together
and we stop fighting and they can't came
to him and said that wasn't good enough
you need to do better or else and he was
like I don't know what you want me to do
then he started getting attacked by woke
people then his friend started calling
him out saying he was a fascist or
something then people actually resigned
and I think he got so angry that a fire
lit by like within him and he was like I
will destroy you and I think he is
deeply deeply angry at these people for
being so crazy but I think he's a calm
strategic collected guy so he's not just
rampaging around screaming he's like
straightening his tie putting his suit
on him being like you mess with the
wrong I think it's commendable that he
was willing to fight back but the fact
that he's running for president he's not
doing it as a serious way to win he's
doing it as a way to up his public
profile in my opinion I don't think he
thinks he's a serious candidate and if
he did want to win something he'd run
for lower office first in my opinion
because a lot of people run just for the
press and I think he's kind of like a
right-wing version of Yang in I think I
think he's running to put ESG on the
debate stage I think I I told him this I
was like I don't think to win I would
support you I I think he hits the nail
on the head with so many of these issues
he's sitting here and he's just like
he's like I'm gonna get in trouble for
saying this but I think about it it's we
got to have some kind of standard and
Civic standard for voting people just
can't be told anybody can vote and then
he came out and said 18 to 26 has to
pass a Civics test which like triggered
all these gen Z people and I'm like
that's not you know you don't say those
things I respect that he said that I
think I don't think he expects to win
you know maybe it's unfair to say maybe
he really is trying but I I think he's a
smart guy who knows the best he can do
is get on stage and say to the world ESG
is destroying us we must stop it
absolutely and we'll see maybe he gets a
cabinet position oh we'll see or not I
mean if the best case scenario is he
goes into bait stage and says no more
ESG I'll take it getting back to what
tonight with the Republicans do because
when Bill Clinton was uh impeached in 92
he had a rally in the in the oval in the
Rose Garden with all Democrats and his
supporters wouldn't it be nice if the
Republicans rallied behind Trump night
they never do on the Republican
conservative side they never rally up on
each other well Vivek said he'll party I
respect it yeah
Iggy the incubus says speaking of
corrupt presidents I recommend razor
fists video Abraham Lincoln American
dictator
oh Abraham Lincoln's got a lot of bad
stuff under his belt the uh the
suspension of habeas corpus and the
corridor stretching from the south up to
uh Pennsylvania
through Maryland the uh what what did
they do they went and arrested a bunch
of the Maryland state legislature
because they were sympathetic to the
South geez yeah
we shouldn't date him too yeah dig up
his corpse
here's here's the moral challenge for
classical liberals the classical liberal
position the deontological position is
that Abraham Lincoln did wrong the
utilitarian and the moralist position is
slavery needed to be stopped and
preserving this country was a good thing
the outcome was undeniably good in a lot
of ways I don't think the outcome after
the Civil War was was universally good I
mean Sherman's March March to the Sea
was was horrifying and monstrous and a
lot and reconstruction was disastrous
too but slavery was just so much worse
than than so much so it's it's a tough
question do you think Abraham Lincoln
was a tyrant I think there's a lot of
bad things he did I think unquestionably
bad things but the outcome man I I am
not in my current present life a
utilitarian the ends don't justify the
means but then you look back at the bad
things Abraham Lincoln did and the end
result being the abolition of slavery in
the 14th Amendment and things that have
genuinely protected people and expanded
civil rights it's like he was certainly
tyrannical tyrants aren't always bad you
have good tyrants as well Tyrant just
means that it's an absolute ruler that's
unrestrained by law or Constitution is
that true I thought that um I thought
that like tyranny is basically just what
you call it when a kingdom goes bad like
Tyrant means a bad King in the same way
that uh oligarchy means a bad
aristocracy and uh
the terms are like classically defined
the guy that put Athens on the map was a
tyrant he walked into the City and was
like I have Athena with me it worked bow
to me and they all did and then he then
he turned Athens into the greatest
tribal Hub on Earth and he was known as
this really great ruler very benevolent
interesting you know I so I remember and
again this is what I learned in school
and I went to public schools to take it
with a grain of salt but what we learned
was that these terms were basically like
tyranny
um and oligarchy and actually even
democracy were originally pejoratives to
refer to different systems when they
went wrong so
um yeah security is just what you call
it when when a king becomes bad and then
like oligarchies when you call it when
an aristocracy I guess but that could I
think the greatest one I remember
learning in public school case study is
Abe Lincoln like he he was a tyrant but
he did good you could argue he did good
anyway you could did some good but then
you could also argue he could have done
that good without the Tyranny arguably
any wartime president is a tyrant in any
political system so that's kind of
that's where we're kind of going with it
that's that's a really good point I
bring up we like to talk about all these
great civil liberties we talk about uh
Classical liberalism and I'm like all
those things disappear the moment of
bomb drops because ain't nobody is going
to be like you're allowed to say all of
these things they're going to be like my
children are in danger get out of my way
that's just it survival becomes
everything
all right what do we got Tyler uh
Brighton says even in prison Trump can
still run for president if he wins he
can pardon himself
yes
wouldn't that be hilarious if that's
what actually happens he's in federal
prison wins and then he's like give me
the papers signs it and they open the
door
that'd be so weird
where are we at
Thomas tjg says politicians bureaucracy
military and agencies are corrupt
because we never held them accountable
if you break the law at any level you
should be held to two times the
punishment because they know better I
agree if you work in government and
break the law there should be special
penalties I think that's effectively how
it works for uh people in the military
because you have military and civilian
criminal criminal procedures
Military Tribunal yeah like if you're if
you're in the Army and then you go off
base and like rob a liquor store you get
military court and you get civilian
courts so it's like double so don't do
that all right don't come back unless
the crimes are really really horrible
like what the Nazis made
take that
thanks for letting me explain myself
yeah yeah well that's something
there are other shows where people would
have jumped on you before you could
finish there have been way too many
instances of History where people made
something illegal that was good or made
something helping and girlfriend was
evil you know helping Anne Frank was
illegal yes you should break the law to
help and Friends yes in that instance
yes that is my opinion that was what the
point you were trying to make was
yeah the law is not morality where are
we at Ryan grissef says someone please
clean the microphone filters after the
stream it's bugging me Amen brother I
got dust for days I got like two years
worth of dust on this lint roller it's
in there I think these need to be opened
up and cleaned once every couple years
or something we just buy new heads we'll
just take this uh thanks this thing
right here and some ASMR look at that
there you go thanks man
I do it once we're muted
and now I gotta throw this down
ASMR rubbing the
all right let's get back to reading
stuff holy crap he died says here in
Missouri we just spanned child sex
changes and ended state-funded adult sex
changes we also made it we also made it
so school children must play sports uh
on T must plan sports teams that match
the sex on their birth certificate
otherwise schools can potentially lose
their funding
very interesting the birth certificate
stuff there's still a lot of challenge
that we have to overcome
as it relates to all that we haven't
solved it but I do believe there's a lot
of good strides being made good good
changes are coming
all right
drag TK says please help great Texas
teacher was in a car wreck while in the
hospital their apartment was robbed
wanted to get them some help Love You
cast crew thanks
but who is the teacher we have no
information sir I don't know how do we
help
all right well
where are we at where are we at let's
grab some more super jets
Mr Big Mr BG sorry says these people
will put Trump in prison he is acting
like this is still a CNN fake news game
and he'll just be impeached but nothing
will happen they are communists this
indictment removes him from the ballot
in multiple States
does it really
so I want to look that up does being
indicted remove you from the ballot in
multiple States
this is the game they are playing people
people have to write them in
but a lot of people will just check
DeSantis you know
and if maybe the goal is to get him off
the ballots in Prime in the primaries
that tennis wins
that's what matters more than the
general a blue State's going to vote
blue
yeah
no it says no to Santos first he says he
won't run against Trump then the man
sits by and says he won't intervene if
Trump is indicted then the man signs HB
269 then launches his campaign with -5
to Charisma then he does this aibs a lot
of bad stuff a lot of bad stuff
disappointing very disappointing
Publius says I think the indictment is
evidence they want Trump to be the
nominee do they think they can beat him
in 2024 they've said it on The View on
The View they were like we want Trump to
be the nominee we don't want to stand a
standard win
they think Trump will lose they said
that in 2016 though right and they're
wrong now because what helped them in
2020 was coveted lockdowns and that was
Trump's fault a lot of it was not all of
it but a lot of it was and people are
like what was he supposed to do about
fauci he couldn't fire fouchies
bureaucracies like he could have
sidelined him easily he could have he
could have assigned him to go work
somewhere nonsensical did it need to be
at every press conference on camera
could have just told him to go chill in
the closet somewhere yep he could have
said I need you to fill out these forms
down in the basement oh we're doing a
press conference come later I don't want
you on any camera any public-facing
position stick in your lab and stay
there but
him and Deborah Burks were just at every
presser instead he hugged him and kissed
him on the nose
Smokey Bones says forget Trump and
DeSantis Tim Scott is the best we've got
Tim Scott actually is pretty awesome but
uh he doesn't reach that level I'm not
sure although a trump Scott ticket what
if Scott's the VP I think it'd be pretty
pretty cool I just saw Tim Scott on The
View that was it was amazing yeah it was
absolutely amazing that dude is
fantastic
so what do you think about I think he's
a calming presence for the President
right he needs it yeah was Tim Scott the
guy who wrote the op-ed in the New York
Times about needing to send in the
gardens no that wasn't that was uh
cotton cotton never mind yeah Tim Scott
is with South Carolina South Carolina
yeah yeah he's right yeah yeah he's good
he's good he's a good dude and he went
on The View and he talked about he
nailed it he said you guys are telling
these young black kids that they can't
succeed that unless they're the the
exception to the rule he's like no you
can't say you can't tell these kids you
gotta tell them to work hard and they
can be successful he's completely right
and then they kept saying you're the
exception you're the exception he's like
what do you mean like I worked hard like
you're telling him he doesn't deserve to
be there exactly because what you're
saying to a person in that situation is
you just got lucky not like you worked
really hard not you earned this you just
got lucky yeah that's that's that that
is that's not cool man was he appointed
to the Senate by Nikki Haley because he
was black or was he appointed because he
was awesome
I think he's right I guess Nikki could
answer that question I think he's a good
dude they seem pretty cool yeah I think
it would be a great ticket
yeah Trump trump Scott he'd be a good
dude some people have mentioned that's
why he's fairly neutral and he's
announcing he's getting name recognition
and then might you know go that route
but that'll be good two first names I
like it oh three first names Timothy
Eugene Scott well I'm big I'm bullish on
people with multiple first names yeah
just to answer you Tim it doesn't
disqualify him according to time uh if
he's indicted it isn't as well time from
running for the election
I couldn't see that couldn't find it
yeah what they said was it removes his
name from the ballots right yeah and if
if the Republicans I'd say they got five
eight percent more African-American vote
the Democratic party's toast yeah it's
true toast and we saw this uh a couple
years ago I think it was 2019. they said
that uh black men are shifting towards
the Republican party they are yeah and
you see those viral videos where there's
like young black men talking about how
Trump's the guy right and there and he's
got street cred
he's a tough guy
beautiful bacon says Trump literally is
a DJ his name is DJ Trump he was merely
living up to his namesake oh my God
dude you got to make that Sheamus
and Trump Jr is DJ Trump too that
literally has to be a slogan DJ Trump in
the house but it's the white house and
it's just a picture of that that's
something that sounds like a sitcom that
would be a really good show it's about a
guy who's a DJ and then he has to move
into the White House because he got beat
up in his neighborhood back in
Washington state is this just the Fresh
Prince
but Trump and Trump was done with South
Florida now he has to go back on Tuesday
to Miami
Sergeant Buck says it wouldn't shock me
if whoever edited that vid had no idea
how to recognize an AI generated image
and just typed Trump and fauci into
Google Google Images Oh that's another
possibility too that's why I'm like when
the people immediately come out and
they're like we're allowed to do it
because Trump posted a rhinoceros they
could have been like it was an error
yeah you know we we Googled the image
and just put him in
yeah I guess so but still very bad I bet
they're going to try to ignore it I'm
gonna look up I don't think you could
just yeah this
that's what I'm calling him from now on
he fake DeSantis
Trump should steal that food yeah old
deep bacon descent is over here
I'm looking at pictures of trump and
family
birthdays on the Wednesday he had an
event uh fun big fundraising event on
Tuesday the 13th at bevminster and now
he has to go to Miami Jesus indictment
so so next Wednesday is his birthday
next Wednesday's Birthday Tuesday was a
big event in Bedminster for the
president for his birthday but Wednesday
now he's being summoned to hand them uh
turn himself in I wonder if they're
planning on announcing it on his
birthday like this all seems so personal
yeah Scott Jeffer says what's your
opinion on The Pick of DeSantis drinking
with young girls was that fake was it
shared by the Trump Camp I'm not simping
for Ron I'm all in for Trump 24 just
asking your opinion I think when that
came out we criticized Trump for doing
it we like all ground and roll the rise
and said it was it was gross or
something and then we were just like you
shouldn't do that stuff but Trump is
kind of a dick like we know this he's
like he's crass in that way and someone
posting a photo
uh that is that is either like not real
or a meme or insulting and then Trump
reposting it being like haha you're dumb
is very very different from a campaign
ad that uses fake images they're they're
bad don't get me wrong I'm not going to
defend Trump for doing that we groaned
and we rolled our eyes but like there's
a whole new level using deep fake images
to smear someone in a political
attackhead
crazy so it was DeSantis as a teacher
allegedly partying with high school
girls
uh that just to be clear of what the
photo was
it was what it was Ron DeSantis as a
teacher allegedly partying with high
school girls was it real was it was
according to Daily Mail
yeah so he would never do such a thing
to spend your real real pick um we might
need to read through a post photo of
Rhonda Sanders as a teacher allegedly
partying with high school girls yeah so
the women could be college girls yeah
was he single then
um yeah but I guess what would be creepy
as a teacher with the high school yeah
I need to dig deeper I don't want to say
the wrong thing about gnarly Marley's as
I mentioned wanting coverage of the AI
Photo Story in a daily wire comment
earlier in the backlash was extreme some
don't care some don't believe it or made
excuses some just bashed you as a
Democrat I was rather shocked yeah it's
culty
very culty
it's weird how insanely culty it is and
it's really off-putting
let's grab some more Super chits grab it
by the balls
just to follow up on that I'm sorry it
says neither post contains evidence that
the girls pictured were under aged or
establishes that anyone photographed was
illegally consuming alcohol Daily Mail
has not been able to verify
um the people in the photo so Rondell
Schmidt says Trump is not pro-choice
Sheamus he was the first president to
ever speak at the pro-life March thank
you guys for doing great work Tim thanks
for helping people financially no I I so
Trump's and this is part of the thing
because elod was asking this earlier
like how could you um pick Trump and you
know over to Santos and like my broader
point is when it comes time to vote in
the primaries I'm going to vote for
who's most pro-life at that time I hope
that that is Trump because I think he's
a stronger candidate overall but what I
will say is when he what he did achieve
many wonderful things for the pro-life
movement but when he does things like
attack DeSantis for this six-week
abortion ban and call it cruel it is
very off-putting for me uh the other
side of that is Trump does just kind of
say things I think that's a very
responsible thing to say I wish he
didn't say it I hope he doesn't believe
it we'll see how his positions end up
shaking out as the campaign goes on I
hope he adopts a hardcore pro-life
position I absolutely hope uh he's not
you know gonna stick with this or like
officially adopt this position that a
six-week abortion ban is bad you say you
vote for the pro-life candidate do you
mean because you like them both you're
gonna go for the one or if there's
someone just a snake that was pro-life
and a really good person who was more
for about or like not right why would
you trust the snakes actually pro-life
like if it was just someone who's like
we want to go to war in the Middle East
we want to conquer we want to destroy
but I'm in a super pro-life would you go
for that guy over if it's a if it's a
choice between a war with the Middle
East and the war with a war with The
Unborn I say neither but I'm going to
vote for the most pro-life possible
candidate even if they're like I think
it's I think it's an interesting
question but like overall my principle
is pro-life yeah that is the most
important thing that we had to get done
with Trump did because of the judges
it's back in the States yeah no exactly
and so that's what I'm saying I think
Trump exactly and so I think and this is
why I praise Trump for that I think that
there were massive pro-life victories
that happened because of trump because
of his appointments I think there's a
good argument to be made that he was the
most pro-life president we've ever had I
mean I'm I'm definitely not talking on
him overall like all right everybody
it's time for the members only show so
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
if you really do like it you think we do
a good job or that we're helping go to
timcast.com click join us so you can
watch that uncensored members only show
in a few minutes it'll be on the front
page at timcast.com you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Adam you want to
shout anything out uh if you can follow
me at my Instagram is adam5pr Twitter at
Adam Matthew and thanks for having me
Tim absolutely hey everybody thank you
guys so much for tuning in I am Ahad
aliyahu a field reporter here at timcast
news please follow us at timcast news on
Twitter for my work and the work of my
colleagues we do a really great job here
my name is Seamus Coughlin I have a
YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes we
just uploaded a cartoon today that I
think you guys are really going to enjoy
it's it's performing pretty well right
now so I think you'll like it it's kind
of about The Little Mermaid and these
other race swapped uh reboots poking fun
at that uh cash grab that happens a lot
um and if you want to support me and my
work go to freedomtunes.com and become a
member you'll get an extra cartoon each
week that the public doesn't get to see
it's just for you I'm Ian Crossland I
was very if it was in a really down
place today I feel a lot better after
hanging out talking about stuff so if
you've got a group of friends out there
go hang out with them and talk about
stuff we're gonna go deep on AI tomorrow
morning too oh yeah on the culture War
It's Gonna be Me Tim and who is this
Zach Voorhees yeah whistleblower from
Google he knows a lot about AI this is
gonna be a great conversation and that
goes up at noon tomorrow Easterns 1 p.m
1 p.m Eastern 1 p.m Eastern tomorrow on
the culture war on YouTube I'll see you
there I will see you there tomorrow as
well and I'm looking forward to seeing
you in the morning uh I enjoyed you guys
a conversation it was great uh let's get
to this after show I'm sure dot com on
Twitter and uh see you there we will see
you all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out